Hi everyone. We're back for part two of
our discussion with Muhammad Hijab's
former wife Aisha and we've got Thaddius
here. How you doing Thaddius?
>> Hello. Happy to be here. We've got Hoda
offscreen. How's it going Hoda?
>> I'm doing well, thanks.
>> And of course, we have Aisha. Aisha, you
hear us?
>> Oh, hi there.
>> Hi. Hi. Hi. How's it going? All right.
So,
>> thank you for having me.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Having me over again.
>> Oh, yeah. Always always glad to always
glad to have you here and help you in
any way we can. Um, Thaddius,
>> why don't you bring everyone up to date?
um I guess kind of the condensed
shortened version of what's been going
on so that we can then uh jump into the
discussion from there.
Mhm. Yes. So Muhammad Hijab uh had a
long-term relationship, not a romantic
relationship, just a long-term
relationship of knowing a woman uh Aisha
who is with us today. After years of uh
conditioning her, grooming her, you
could say, he eventually proposed to
marry her. He promised this would be a
normal Islamic marriage that he would
provide full rights. Um the only
condition being that she would not tell
his first wife because his first wife
would not be okay with the arrangement.
Uh but he would provide financial
support. He'd be part of her life. Uh be
a father for her child and so on and so
forth. Have additional children with
her. As soon as the uh marriage took
place or the nika, he immediately
changed the terms. He said, "This is
going to be a sex-only marriage. We're
just going to meet at hotels. And by the
way, I will uh don't worry. I will try
not to get you pregnant." Aisha said,
"No, this isn't what I signed up for. Uh
this is not what you promised. You are
lying to me. If you're not going to give
me what you promised, then give me a
divorce." So that's what hijab did and
gave her divorce. After that uh he
continued to abuse her over text
messages. Uh he was extremely angry to
put all this effort in I guess to
condition a woman to to be his uh
sexonly so-called wife really you know
sexual abuse here really has nothing to
do with a marriage really has nothing to
do with being a wife. Um he was very
upset about that, very angry, continued
to send her all kinds of threatening
text messages and angry messages and as
a result uh she said
this isn't right. This is this is
something very wrong has happened here.
Let me go and uh get some scholars
opinions, ask some Muslims for help. She
went to a bunch of different Muslims.
Some said yes, what hijab did was wrong,
but I don't want to get involved. Leave
me out of this. I I don't want to be
associated with this. Others just said
that yeah, hijab he maybe it wasn't like
the best thing in the world but it's
also okay Islamically. So in the face of
all that uh she did eventually find one
individual who's willing to help her.
She shake Muhammad Tran. Tranane
negotiated a settlement in which hijab
would apologize and Aisha would have the
opportunity to make a public statement
go on Ali Dawa's uh YouTube channel and
kind of reveal this is happening without
saying anything about it being Muhammad
hijab to say I I was tricked by this guy
and this is what happened. Other sisters
be aware that there's people out there
that are trying to do this thing. So be
viligent. uh be be aware of this as a
possibility and don't allow yourself to
be tricked. That was recorded. Um when
Muhammad Hijab saw the program, he's
like, "Never mind. People might figure
out this is me. We're not going to we're
not going to release this. Delete this."
Ali Dawa. Ali Dala of course complied
and deleted it. Uh Aisha eventually got
in touch with a Muslim named Salman.
Runs a channel called Behind Veils.
After a thorough investigation lasting
six months, Salman also tried to
negotiate a settlement behind closed
doors, tried to get Hijab to cooperate
and instead hijab just lied. Said he
never knew her when he was confronted on
that. Changed the story. Yeah, I knew
her but she was a crazy stalker. Uh
she's making the whole thing up. Salmon
said that's nonsense. We have tons of
evidence. So, if you're not going to
cooperate, if you're not going to do
this Islamically, we're going to have to
go public. And that's what ended up
happening. They dropped that video. U
Muhammad Hijab responded on an anonymous
channel using an AI narrator.
Ali Dawa jumped in. Ali Dala responded.
Salman continued to drop more and more
and more and more evidence. Case built
built built built. Then at near the end
it was revealed that Muhammad Job was
blackmailing Shik Trane to keep him
silent, keep him from revealing
anything.
Then uh we had part one of this
interview and since then new news has
dropped. Salman apparently got access to
a group chat in which Muhammad hijab and
numerous other Dies are uh members and
they were conspiring behind closed doors
to conceal everything and that takes us
up to where we are today.
All right, so um that brings everyone up
to date. We've got a link to the behind
veils video where uh Thaddius just
mentioned uh in the description box.
Definitely want to watch that. Uh lots
of information in there. Just wanted to
highlight uh two things. One where uh
Hijab brings me up and then we'd like uh
Sister Aisha's uh reaction to something
about her in there, which is uh possibly
the most disturbing um thing to emerge
from that uh those text messages. But uh
one of the things we have here and so
we're looking at the this is from these
are screenshots from Salman's
presentation on these text messages. So
he he's added some of his own notes over
on the side. We're not talking about
those. We're talking about the the texts
that are up on the screen. But this was
a WhatsApp group from with I think 75
Muslim daisies who were all working
together with Muhammad Hijab uh as part
of a group that was meant to discredit
discredit Sister Aisha and to uh rescue
Muhammad Hijab from criticism.
So, we have here we have here Ali Dawa
and we're going to look at this one and
we've got Muhammad Hijab's response.
We're going to take a look at that as
the as far as the uh most disturbing
ones. Um, but here this isn't really
disturbing. It's this one's kind of
funny, but Muhammad Hijab says to the
group, "Salam guys, I heard that David
Wood knew that something would happen. I
heard that David Wood knew that
something would happen. That there would
be some kind of scandal and that there
is a video that proves it. Does anyone
have that video? We need it. Um, so this
is the hilarious thing that I have a
video that proves it.
So, hijab here says because this is
because me and uh AP were talking about
this in live streams, but hijab way back
in January started talking about Elon
Musk. He posted a video and he was
posting tweets saying that someone from
someone with Elon Musk had contacted him
and sent him a warning that if he
doesn't stop his uh powerful criticisms
of Elon Musk and doing his da in that
regard and whatever that Elon Musk was
going to use his uh untold billions of
dollars to to frame Muhammad hijab for a
scandal and that that story that story
was so beyond ridiculous that it was
obvious what was going done. This is a
move that hijab stole from Andrew Tate.
When Andrew Tate found out that he was
about to be arrested, he put out a
message to his followers about how uh
people were going to frame him for
crimes and uh this was all to discredit
him for for you know over his powerful
inspiring message to young men. So
anyway, uh hijab copied that. Obviously,
obviously, obviously. If he's sitting
here saying Elon Musk is about to frame
me for a scandal, there's a scandal
that's about to come out and he wants to
uh throw people off the trail. So,
that's that was the entire basis for me
realizing a scandal was about to come
out
and
somehow hijab thinks that there's a
video that I had some sort of proof or
evidence. No, it the the video in
question, the relevant video that proves
that the scandal was about to come out
was Muhammad Hijab's video saying that
Elon Musk was about to frame him. So
anyway, just wanted to point that out
that uh it's kind of weird that this guy
lets lets information out, lets the cat
out of the bag himself, exposes himself,
and then is wondering where the evidence
is that's exposing him. Dude, it's you.
You expose yourself. you exposed
yourself, man. All right. So, I want to
get uh Sister Aisha's reaction to uh
these messages here. And we want to go
uh I guess I'll start in the No, I'll
start at the top. So, someone says she's
straight up mental, referring to Sister
Aisha. Says she did admit to having
mental issues online and also in her
email to us. Ali Dawa says, "We don't
want to push her to suicide." and then
he corrects himself.
So that's from Ali Dawa. And we have
Muhammad Hijab's response. To be honest,
Aki, if she's an apostate and an enemy
of Islam, we shouldn't care. So this is
Muhammad Hijab saying they shouldn't
care. This group of 75
uh Muslim men in Da. If Aisha is an
enemy of Islam and you're wondering why
is she an enemy of Islam because she's
uh questioning Muhammad hijab and
calling his character into question and
uh why would she be an apostate
uh because she expressed some doubts
which in another context Ali Dawa
thought was totally fine totally fine to
express doubts if you're Sneo but if
you're Aisha that means I guess you're
an apostate but hijab thinks okay if we
can put her in the apostate category in
the enemy of Islam category. We
shouldn't care if we push her to end her
own life. So notice this is this is a
question about how their actions were
going to affect her. And Hijab's
response is if she's an enemy of Islam,
we shouldn't care. We shouldn't care if
she ends up ending her own life. So, uh,
Sister Aisha, we'd like to get your
thoughts on all of this because this is
again probably the most disturbing part
about, uh, about the texts that were
leaked.
>> Um, these texts, uh, made me feel, uh,
sick.
Um, yeah. So, I felt sick and I had
fever and I couldn't believe what I was
reading. Um, brother Salman tends to
work on most of his videos, majority of
the parts of his videos, the editing and
the information for um um like for
safety reasons uh to be really honest.
Like he tries his best to uh keep hold
of
most disturbing information away from me
uh to not hurt me emotionally.
And I saw that information when it was
released
and uh these people I spent my own money
just this last Ramadan.
I checked out their their projects.
I was paying for their projects. I was
trying to learn and deal with my
questions from their own work.
And throughout all these years, these
people are my own family. And I'm not
going to sugarcoat anything. As I said
before, I'm still working on these
things. So I am not here to say that I
have den denounced Islam or I am against
them or against Islam. But what I can
see clearly here in front of me is
extremely disturbing.
These are actions of devils.
This is the description of devils.
These are my own family. Where is the
investigation?
Where is the digging of of of the
information? Where is that we have in
the Quran? Whatever he says, they are
believing it. They are taking it at face
value. They are taking it for for his
words. There is no investigation.
Absolutely nothing. There there are
diagnosis here that are being made based
on one single text or comment or
whatever. I do not think that any of
them do actually believe anything about
the mental health issues. I think all
these things are being just used to
cover up on Muhammad Hijab's actions.
This was extremely disturbing. It made
me feel extremely sick and I just simply
can't believe what I'm reading.
>> Oda, uh, what are your thoughts on this?
>> To be honest, when I when I first saw
this video, I was horrified.
I was somebody who went through my own
trauma in the Muslim community that
still has an impact on me today. And I
just couldn't help but think these are
the same guys who are getting paid
thousands upon thousands of dollars to
speak. They set up booths and they they
preach Islam and they are trying to
invite people to Islam. Women
especially. And I I can't help but
think, you know, these same women that
they will preach Islam to and invite to
Islam, their lives don't matter to them
in the context of they're going to use
you. They want to marry you and use you
and throw you away and you get pushed to
deep depression, suicide, anything. They
don't care if you die. They the lives of
women do not matter to these guys.
Yeah, this is some seriously uh
seriously sick stuff. And keep in mind,
guys, this is Muhammad Hijab
talking about his ex-wife
who
tried everything she possibly could,
tried everything she possibly could to
deal with this behind the scenes, not to
expose him even, just to get other
Muslim women to realize uh that this is
something that's happening. And because
she tried to let people know, let Muslim
women know,
not to let men take advantage of them in
this way. That was enough for all of
this, for all of this um attempt to
destroy her credibility. And hijab knows
that she's
vulnerable in all this. And so the
concern arises, what if we push her so
hard uh destroy her life so much that we
actually push her to end her own life?
Hijab's response is we shouldn't care.
We shouldn't care. She's an she's an
apostate and an enemy of Islam. Again,
talking about his
ex wife.
So yeah, this is uh this is bad stuff.
But again, ladies and gentlemen, you can
get all of that. Um, you can get all of
that and a lot more over on the uh
Behind the Veils uh channel and we've
got the link to the most recent video in
the description box.
Really, really, really messed up uh
messed up stuff. Um Aisha, anything else
you'd like to share before we get into
some uh other issues? Uh it's basically
for the new video, for the new behind
veils video. Everyone's going to have to
go ahead and watch that for themselves.
We wanted to draw attention to
um some of the issues uh with the DA
community and how uh hypocritical these
guys are and how this is still a
problem. People who um go against the
grain and expose something in the
community uh can be attacked. So we want
to sort of revisit the issue of Imam
Nick. But anything else you wanted to
cover from the uh information that was
released there?
Um this is something I was um
reconsidering. I was hesitant uh in
sharing this these details because these
are very personal uh issues
um very sensitive issues and I hope that
people can can um manage and and
accommodate my my English because this
is not my first language.
Um so the situation here is all these
things and all these details that have
happened had actually really pushed me
to the edge.
And when I look at these comments and I
look at what I've been going through in
the past 2 years mentally
um the implications of all his actions
uh the smear campaign that happened and
started actually very early on since I
started reaching out to people even
before I came out public. the stories
that he spread uh amongst those who knew
about the marriage. Um the way he acted,
the psychopathic treatment and and all
the interactions and all the lies, the
deception and him basically turning into
a monster. something I've never seen of
him in towards the Muslims and the way
he promoted himself as like oh all those
actions I do even with the non-Muslims
is just for the show is just like for to
create the views and so on and I'm
actually really nice and um he's been
promoting how he reached out to even AP
and in a soft way and he was like you
know um we let's have a good
conversation
um uh like and I think even AP has um
spoken about this before.
But then when I saw how like all these
things were not real, they were not true
based on my own experience. the way he
was trying absolutely anything and
everything just to cover up on his face
rather than really providing a real
apology and rectifies his actions
because even the apology that he
provided was not um was not a real one.
The apology that Sheikh Muhammad speaks
about it was not a real apology. That
apology was followed with the the
WhatsApp text conversations that was
were shared and that conversation on
WhatsApp just was one. There were a few
other conversations similar to that. All
these things and the implications of
them on my life and my child as well
pushed me a few time to attempt to analy
myself.
So when I read that message that was
posted a couple of days ago,
I was horrified.
This person doesn't even care about
absolutely nobody. It's not just um a
person who was a wife to him.
I wanted to raise awareness and this is
why I decided to accept your offer to
come on your channel. This was my aim
from the get-go. I wanted to create a
change because the actions he was
spreading amongst men are horrible and
they destroy other people's lives.
>> Yes, they do. And so you you're right.
Um as far as hijab, not just with you,
but he really doesn't care seem to care
about any anyone but himself. I mean,
just think he could have dealt with
this. He could have dealt with this a
long time ago and quietly and just
couldn't couldn't bear the thought
couldn't bear the thought of not getting
his way and not being in complete
control and he's willing to just destroy
everything around him um all for
himself. So, yeah, that's a serious
issue. But the the other issue uh as far
as something that does absolutely need
to be dealt with is the fact that so
many people were on board with this and
all he has to do is say, "Hey, here's
the situation. Um, let's all work
together. Let's all work together in
destroying this woman and destroying her
life and so on." Uh, and then again,
when it gets brought up, hey, what if we
push her too hard and she ends her own
life? He says, "Ha, we shouldn't care."
And keep in mind that's he's the he's
the sort of leader of these guys. He's
the leader. And you would have Muslims
in that group who are thinking, "Wow,
that would be really bad to push a woman
to end her own life. That would be
really bad." And he's saying, "No, from
an Islamic perspective, we shouldn't
care." So, this man has influence over
other people, and it's not he's not
using his influence for good. He's using
his influence for evil. And uh yeah, I I
can guarantee if uh he sat down with a
psychiatrist uh who analyzed him, he
would be very quickly diagnosed with
narcissistic personality disorder. Um
because he's a total narcissist. He's at
the center of the universe. Everything
revolves around him.
Okay, so uh again everyone, that link
the link to that video is in the
description box. uh the behind veils
video really really really messed up
disturbing stuff but um takes you
through a lot of those a lot of those
text messages. Uh Thaddius we wanted to
um
you sent me some video clips that we
wanted to go through sort of exposing
the hypocrisy of these guys but to to
sort of um tie things back in.
Actually Hoda you know you know about
the Imam Nick thing right?
>> I do. I have uh I have a lot of
familiarity with the Imomnik scenario.
>> Yeah, that that's kind of what what we
want to cover. There's just so much
hypocrisy involved in all of this. And
then so that's a problem, the hypocrisy
as we're about to see, but also this
this issue of anyone who kind of goes
against the grain and um exposes exposes
what's going on uh behind the scenes is
is uh is is a target is a target for um
just their lives being ruined. So,
what's going on with We covered We
covered a bit of um we covered the story
of Imam Nick last time, but uh just
wanted to recap with a clip or two. Uh
what's the story here?
>> So, with Imam Nick after calling out the
child abuse at the Irving Masid, he
consulted many imams like Yaser Kadi,
Omar Suliman, Yaser Bir, Suave Webb, and
silence. Nobody wanted to touch this
situation with a 10-ft pole. Nobody
wanted to listen to him. Nobody wanted
to help. They wanted to stay out of it.
There's this whole culture of protecting
these types protecting each other,
protecting these types of people and
just staying silent about it. And what
happened to Imam Nick for speaking out
about it and trying to seek help from
other imams in his community? He was
shunned and he's struggled for the past
six, seven years now to get his life
together again and to rebuild from what
happened. He's had trouble finding
employment. He's struggled financially.
He has a wife and children and he's not
having a good time being shunn from the
community. This is what happens if you
go against the Dawa mafia, the greater,
you know, mafia. This group of people
And this is uh
this ties into the story with sister
Aisha in the sense that um Imam Nick saw
something that was definitely wrong and
had knew he had to draw attention to it.
It's not something you can sweep under
the rug and somehow in the minds of
people that makes him the bad guy. And
again, it it's similar with Sister Aisha
because she saw a problem, namely that
this wasn't just something that was
going to happen to her. This is
something that's happening to other
women. So, she realizes she can't just
uh keep this quiet.
And that makes her the bad guy to the
point where it makes her it makes her an
apostate in their minds. So, this is uh
yeah, let's go ahead and watch let's go
ahead and watch uh a clip from Imam Nick
explaining explaining things a bit.
>> If doing the right thing puts me in line
with the wrong people that you don't
like, I don't care if the only help I
have to save a drowning boy is somebody
who you find appalling. And I'm sure you
can think of some names.
I'm not going to not act because I'm
afraid of how you will think it will
reflect on me because of who you think I
associate with. Point number seven that
I made Muslims look bad. Well, if your
Islam is grabbing children's crotches
and sucking on their face or covering up
for those who do. anyone who didn't see
uh story last time, I mean uh Huda
shared it a bit there, but uh we saw
video clips last time uh where he was
describing the situation and someone was
abusing a child. Again, we we've been
through this, but
the issue here is since he brings this
up and exposes it to non-Muslims,
therefore it's like he's conspiring with
non-Muslims to attack Islam or something
and therefore that makes him someone
who's conspiring with the enemy somehow
uh against Islam. Again, same thing they
did with Sister Aisha that because she's
sharing this information and uh even
sharing it with people who are going to
use it, therefore she's conspiring and
collaborating with the enemies of Islam
and needs to be targeted. Um just like
IM Nick here,
>> I didn't make you look bad. I merely put
a mirror in front of you. And the mirror
doesn't make you look bad. It just shows
you who you are. And I have nothing to
do with whatever version of Islam that
is. You want to make Muslims look good,
you should have done the right thing.
You should have said something. You
should have done something. My Islam
doesn't care how you think or how
anybody else thinks it looks. You have
the opportunity to do the right thing.
One of my best friends from college
who's a Roman Catholic and knows a thing
or two about this sort of stuff said to
me, "Man, you served up your community a
grand slam." And they struck out.
>> Wow. Um, I have to say that's uh one of
the one of the good things that came out
of this entire situation is that uh
we've we've
we've come across some Muslims that we
really like. That is
>> we really like we really like sister
Aisha. We really like uh the work that
Salman has done doing awesome stuff. And
I have to say I wasn't familiar with
Imam Nick before but I really like that
guy. you know, you and I uh we strongly
oppose Islam, but through this we've
learned that there are good Muslims that
we can agree with. And Aisha is saying
that she strongly opposes what we do,
but she's learned through this that
there are good people on the Christian
side or uh on the atheist side that are
willing to stand up for what is right.
>> And uh I can I can
>> absolutely like um David shared
Oh, sorry. I wanted to say that you
shared your story of uh your mom which
is a very personal thing but you decided
that you're going to share that in one
of the comments
and um I think if we can get together on
what is good and I've said this many
times I would appreciate that we all get
to share our opinion um in a way that
would keep everyone you know safe
basically and away from blasphemy and
mockery.
But obviously this is my own opinion
>> to to be honest like from my end. Sister
Aisha, I I knew of Imam Nick many years
ago when I converted. Like I I was
looking for converts to relate to online
and I found him and I liked his content
and he was a convert like me. He's a
wholesome family man. Like I always and
I still feel like and I know that Imam
Nick is a good human being especially
after what he did. He sacrificed himself
for the greater good of his community.
Right? So again, I've mentioned this
before. When it comes to somebody in
humanity being wronged, I'm going to
side with the person in humanity being
wronged. It doesn't matter what
background you come from. And even with
Imm
recently, he had a GoFundMe. There was
one that Salman set up for him. And then
there was another one. I was so
surprised. Imm Nick was just in a
serious car accident. And I just have
such a heart for Imam Nick that I shared
his GoFundMe and I I helped raise funds
for him to help rebuild his life. So for
me, it doesn't necessarily matter, you
know, Muslim, non-Muslim, Christian, it
doesn't matter if you're a good person.
and you you take on a sacrifice like
this for your community, I'm going to
want to stand up for you.
>> This is what created the crisis of faith
for me. Um because any human being with
the least sound
heart
would take action,
the least of actions. The silence is
deafening and it's terrifying. It's
traumatizing for me. No one could
possibly understand the degree of trauma
this silence is creating um spiritually
and otherwise. Um yeah and I think you
are right and I am appalled at the
silence from the Muslim side. Brother
Salman has done like great work, amazing
that work is is unprecedented
and he did put his life um at risk along
with all the team that worked with him
and um I appreciate everybody who would
stand up for what is good and what is
true. That that that is just really
amazing work. That's all I could say.
Yeah, that is uh
um it is interesting. We all uh we all
uh everyone here right now shares that
in common that we're willing to uh stand
up for what we think is is uh right and
we'll stand our ground even in uh even
when we're being attacked and so on and
uh I imam Nick is in that category,
Salman is in that category. So, um,
yeah, on on the on the issue, this is
something that came up uh in a recent
live stream where I mentioned that when
we're listening to the Da guys, I I have
an inclination to attack Islam because
they're behaving terribly and
uh very evil behavior. and my
inclination is to
go after the religion you're telling me
about when you're being especially evil
and so on. But then when uh talking or
hearing from sister Aisha or Salman just
when we're watching clips I have the
opposite inclination like hey uh you're
you're doing uh you're doing good things
here. I don't want to I don't want to
attack your I don't want to attack your
prophet or anything right now while uh
you're doing good things. So uh it it's
just interesting because I I started
dealing with Islam way back in the day
just because my best friend was a
Muslim. So my best friend in college was
a Muslim and we were having discussions
about Islam and so everything all all
these discussions about Islam are in the
context of simultaneously being best
friends with a Muslim. So there's no
there's no hatred for him. He's my best
friend. Later on, eventually after years
later, he becomes a Christian and then
uh start it took him about a month
before he got his first death threat and
it was attached to his car. So, someone
who knew someone who knew where he was.
Um,
but then you know just the the insults
and the abuse that is piled on him, it
made me want to blast away at Islam more
because now now it's it's not my best
friend who's the Muslim. It's the
Muslims are were were all these people
who are just heaping insults and abuse
and threatening my threatening my best
friend threatening his life. And so
natural inclination to go into uh into
attack mode. So, just wanted to point
that out there for everyone who um you
know raises up the DA guys and puts them
on these pedestals. Uh when they behave
like Muhammad Hijab does, uh that makes
us more inclined to
attack your religion. when you're
behaving well and standing up for what's
right like I imam Nick or Salman or
Aisha that makes us even if we still
want to criticize Islam and we still
want to bring up points about why we
disagree with it or why we think it's
false and so on it's not the same
inclination to to attack it in the same
way that we sometimes do. So, um, the
point here is if you really want to
protect Islam from criticism, everyone
out there, not not necessarily from
criticism, because I I said we'd still
do that, but, you know, from mockery or
insults, probably don't prop up these
guys that that bring that that bring out
bring that out of people with their
behavior, though. Anyway, um, but here
we all here we're all getting along.
Here we're all getting along because
we're on the same page about how women
should not be treated.
All right, Thaddius, we wanted to jump
into some clips about because we're
pointing out that this is a problem in
the DA community, especially when it's
one of their own, but we've got a couple
of clips from EF Dawa here.
And
>> yeah, a Oh, go ahead.
>> A Christian calls into their show um
shortly after the story breaks and kind
of asks them about it. And they're like,
"Oh, well, we don't know anything. We
don't want to talk about someone's
private life or whatever." And then he
kind of like pushes the issue and
says,"Well, what would you need uh for
this to to be a problem and then they
give a standard and then
lo and behold that standard is quickly
met in you know things that develop
after that show and then they're asked a
little while later what the standard are
is and it completely has changed."
>> All right, let's check out uh the first
clip you referenced there. Look, I'm not
going to defend Muhammad hijab if he's
done something wrong. I will say
straight to him on his face that hijab,
this is wrong. That's how Muslims are.
The Quran tells us clearly, stand up for
justice even against yourselves, against
your parents, against your family,
against your kin, whether one is rich or
poor. We're not here to cover anything
up.
>> So, you're saying this was in the
context of him being asked uh about this
situation. and they don't know anything
about it, but they're saying, "Yeah, if
there if he did do something wrong, we
would call even him out. We because
that's how we are. We will stand up."
Wait, hang on. This is seriously these
guys saying we're going to stand up for
what's right. And even if it's Muhammad
Hijab, that's the kind of community we
are. We're the community that would
stand up against him and challenge him
and say, "You're wrong here. You need to
repent
>> and atone for what you've done.
Yep. Exactly. Yeah. So the the guy at
the bottom of the screen is the one who
asked the question. Uh he basically was
like Muhammad Job has been accused of,
you know, X Y and Z. What do you think
about that? And they're like oh you know
we don't know. We don't have any
information about this. And then the
guy's like well what if it's true,
right? What if it's true? And then that
they're responding in this way.
and you sent me two more clips where
they seem something seems to have
changed their mind at some point. But
let's see.
>> We don't we're not here to spread
rumors. If something is established, you
can go and speak directly to Muhammad
hijab on one of his streams when he's on
his streams and you can ask him
directly. We're not going to be doing
that cheap. Pull, you know, get your
popcorn ready and let's start discussing
about people's lives and let's start
judging other who has the right to judge
anyone anyway, Frank. Anyway, come in
there, Frank, and before we get the next
guest on.
>> Wait one second. One second. So, this
clip continues, but uh little confused
here. So, this is actually the in the
same discussion. At first, at first they
say yes, we would we would call him out
even if it's Muhammad hijab and then
they instantly start saying but you know
if it's a private stuff and so on we
don't want to we don't want to become we
don't want to become gossip channels or
something like that or or we don't want
we don't want to focus on the drama.
>> I played two clips just to be clear that
you know it wasn't continuous. there was
like some interaction in between and
basically the guy just kept pushing him
right after they said they'd call him
out and he's like well there's all this
evidence it's already out there and he's
like well you know you know you know we
don't want to get into all that we don't
want to get into gossip if that's not
what this show is about
>> oh okay so the first was we don't know
>> we need to see evidence then he's like
okay well the evidence is out there that
salmon just posted it it's on behind
veils you can go watch it and then like
what no no no no you can go ask job you
can go ask what his response responses
to uh the evidence.
>> Very strange. Very strange. But let's
let them continue here.
>> I I have a comment about this this
video.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. I think the this Christian person
when he what he was bringing up was way
much more of value than what they made
it seem like because his question was
evolving around what Muhammad Hijab was
preaching from an Islamic perspective.
Um and uh he was sharing that on the
bitter truth
and uh hijab was coming across like um
whatever kind of uh marriage with the
intention of divorce which he called
previously in 2019
um sexual exploitation of women. If it's
done right, it doesn't matter how long
it takes. It doesn't matter whether or
not a man has a the reason to divorce.
He doesn't even have to bring forward
any kind of justification.
He can do it uh straight away. He can
divorce straight away. He can do
whatever he feels like doing. He
shouldn't be questioned at all. And it's
Islamically okay. This is his argument.
This is Muhammad Hijab's argument. You
can deceive a woman regardless of her
situation. Whether she's young, she's
old, she's she's vulnerable, she's not
vulnerable. For me, it's wrong. for him.
No, it's Islamically valid. And this is
the whole issue. This is the whole
problem that we are fighting here. And
this is what this Christian was bringing
up. He said to them that what Muhammad
Hijab did and what he's preaching is he
claims is Islamically valid.
And I'm sure we are going to be able to
hear that from him uh in a minute right
now.
>> All right, let's see
>> a couple things. Um, you asked about
Christians and slander. So Jesus set out
what you do when a when a brother sins
that you go you go and speak to him
yourself and then you then you if he
won't listen to you then you take two
others with you as witnesses and if you
still won't listen then you take it to
the church. So you don't spread rumors.
>> So uh he's
comparing what they're saying with what
Jesus taught. And then we've got the
next EFA clip here.
>> Are you slandering Jimmy Swagot?
>> No. No. Hold on a second. Frank,
>> why are you bringing up an internet
rumor?
>> Hold on a second.
>> How do you know Jimmy Swaget did that?
Why are you plucking his name?
>> Because he admitted it. He He cried on
screen for
>> So has Muhammad hijab I think he's
admitted this marriage.
>> No, he didn't. No, he didn't. That's the
point.
>> Oh, so I I get it. I get it. So the idea
was
that
let let me see if I understand the
progression here. So they he someone
asked them asked them about their
reaction to the Muhammad hijab uh
scandal which was breaking news. Then
their response was of course we'd call
that out. If if Muhammad Hijab is doing
whatever he's being accused of doing and
lying and this and that then of course
we would call him out. And then sounds
like the guy kept pressing and saying,
"But it sounds like he did do that
stuff. So you guys going to call him
out?" And then it's no, we don't want to
we don't want to we don't want to f we
don't want to deal with drama. We don't
want to talk about people's lives and so
on. As they're sort of realizing, oh, he
actually did this and we've just agreed
that we would call him out for it. We
need to change this uh very quickly. And
then as he as uh as this guy looks like
his name is goes by English fellow but
if English fellow so English fellow
starts um comparing what they're saying
with what Jesus said and then at some
point they say ah but what about Jimmy
Swagger look you've got that scandal
you've got that scandal and he said wait
a minute why you bringing that up why
you bringing because they just laid it
down we don't talk about you know
scandals and stuff like that we're not
interested in the scandals but then they
bring up Jimmy Swagger and he calls them
>> uh calls him out for that.
>> So this is a he calls back a different
day. Um so that you're now in where he
calls back the second day. So the first
time they're like, you know, we don't
spread rumors as Muslims. Uh and he
basically his point was that he's not
spreading a rumor, right? This has gone
way beyond spreading a rumor stage.
There's evidence there. There's multiple
witnesses. Uh it was attempted to be
resolved in private. Now it's been
brought public. So you see I by
Christian standards I'm not spreading
rumors and presumably by your standards
as well, right? I'm not really spreading
rumors and then then the conversation
basically ends after that or they force
him to talk about whatever else they
wanted to talk about but as far as the
hijab part goes basically ends after
that clip. So then like he calls back
like a week later or a few days later. I
don't remember the exact timeline, but
he calls back and he's like, "Well,
uh, well, you know, he calls back and
they're like, "Oh, you better not be
coming here to talk about hijab again.
That's not what this show's all about."
Or whatever. And he's like, "Well, you
know, that more evidence has come out
and and he's done this." And then then
they immediately go, "Well, Jimmy
Swagger, blah blah blah blah blah." And
he's like, "Wait a minute. Wait a
minute. You're just spreading rumors.
You're just spreading rumors." Because
that was their standard, right? If
you're talking about someone you don't
personally know, it's spreading rumors.
>> Obviously, the English fellow doesn't
think they're actually spreading rumors,
right? It's established fact that Jimmy
Swagger got himself into trouble with
the prostitute. And they're like, "Oh,
well, the difference is he admitted it."
And then English fell goes, "Well, hijab
did admit it. He didn't like come out in
a video and say it, but he there's texts
where he admits it, right? He he we now
know from what's been revealed that he
had admitted it basically in the group
chat of the 75 Dies. So yeah, he
admitted it and now they're like, "No,
we we need to hear it in his words or it
doesn't count." So that's the standard
now.
This is also this is also seriously
disturbing. I mean, so they're saying if
you are actually if you get exposed for
something and you acknowledge it and you
admit what you've done, then they can
attack you. But if you just lie about
it, then you can't be attacked.
>> It's hindered. Yes.
>> Regardless of the amount of evidence
that's going to be presented about it.
And this is what disturbed me again
faith-wise because I am in the field of
dawa. All my life I go around empirical
evidence is not the only type of
evidence that you go by.
Empirical evidence is not the only type
of evidence you go by. But here it's
like regardless of the amount of
evidence you gather, the WhatsApp
conversation was crossch checked by
Sheikh Muhammad
and it's Muhammad hijab that that
conversation was confirmed that it's
Muhammad Hijab who sent it to me and he
told him like like that I shared all
that conversation with Shikh Muhammad at
the early stages like um everything was
confirmed. we've got all these types of
evidence and we are being told it's not
enough and I am like okay so what is
enough his own words on the bitter truth
on podcasts all of those things are not
enough we're not talking here about only
the marriage and divorce we're talking
about the details of what what has been
preached the details and the horrifying
uh like attitude of um it's okay just
using abuse and then throw women later
on you don't need to answer any
questions about that. It was the the the
psychopathic treatment that happened to
me in person. It was um like claiming
that Allah is okay with all of these
things. But no one stood up against him,
you know. Um so him coming out to say
yes this is what I have done is not the
only type of evidence that is required
to establish these facts. No, we have
actually provided way much more than
enough evidence.
>> You you know what I think is part of the
problem here too, especially in this
video. I think like in Islam, there's
like the culture of no backbiting. And I
think what a lot of Muslims do is even
when they know somebody is wrong and
they know, you know, there's strong
evidence that something happened, they
use the whole no backbiting rule as a
way to kind of like evade, you know,
like approaching somebody or or forcing
people to face accountability. They kind
of hide behind this whole well, I'm not
going to backbite. We don't know. We
don't have evidence. Even though they
do, any like reasonable person can
deduce like what happened here.
Yeah. And again, for me, the the the
issue is I mean, as far as what's coming
out right here is that we tend to think
that if you've done something wrong,
it's better it's better to be honest
about it and to confess what you've
done, to admit where you're wrong, and
to to to
try to avoid that in the future. Right?
That's that's part of that's part of the
process for becoming a better person.
Hey, I was wrong. Let me change. I
apologize to everyone. I And it sounds
like they're saying, "Hey, if you
actually end up confessing like Jimmy
Swagger did, then then we can it's okay
to go after you. And if you're Muhammad
Hijab and you just double down and keep
lying and destroying everyone around you
to cover up your lie, then we will never
criticize that." It's like, what? No.
What's wrong with you? Anyway,
it's just a weird weird weird situation.
Okay, so wanted to get into uh a
detailed post from Muhammad Hijab, but
um
as far it is really interesting. You
take Ali Dawa, you take Ali Dawa and he
says, "Yes, Muslim women, if someone's
doing this sort of thing, then you
should expose him." him and then he
finds out it's Muhammad Hijab. Changes
his story. We see the same thing from
these guys. Yes, we would even call out
Muhammad Hijab. Oh, he's actually doing
this stuff. Oh, no, no, no. We're
definitely not going to call him out
cuz, you know, he would just have to
admit it himself, which he's not going
to do. And so everyone's changing their
story here, but um
uh sister Aisha, why don't you go ahead
and um
share any thoughts you have on Muhammad
Hijab changing his story about what he
wanted uh with the marriage and so on.
>> Uh yes. So this whole situation is a
wave of an ideology that Muhammad hijab
did go ahead and rooted it in Islam and
that's what has created the greatest
problem although the initial problem is
a big problem which is the exploitation
of women. Now it has become a greater
problem which is claiming that Allah is
okay with it. Right? So, we've got two
tiers, two levels of great issues here.
And so, the whole idea is you can go
ahead, I'm talking in general, is you
can go ahead and and lie to these women.
Tell her, "I divorced my wife. I hate my
wife. I'm going to divorce my wife."
Tell her, "I'm not married." Even if you
are. Tell her it's it's a love
connection. It's mutual. I liked you all
this time. Tell her we've got things in
common. Just do anything. Just play her
up as a player that a street player, not
like a religious um grounded man who has
daughters.
Not no not like someone who's posing
like righteous and and religious. Go
play up women, you guys, just to avoid
pornography and adultery. It's okay. And
this is going to replace adultery and
pornography because it's going to be
temporary. It's meant to be temporary.
It's meant to be played up. It's meant
to be orchestrated. And we are going to
be here to have your backs. We're going
to help you. We're going to teach you
ways. We're going to give you the tips
and tricks and go ahead and do this as
many times as you can. There is
absolutely nothing wrong with it. And
he's been preaching this in in
worldwide. Basically, he's got millions
of followers. Everyone is listening
listening to him and and and and he's
going ahead and saying this is an
Islamic teaching and it's okay. This is
called a marriage with the intention of
divorce and it is not okay. It's
destroying women's lives. their kids if
they are single mothers are looking at
their moms being used and abused and
broken and uh all the implications and
and the consequences of this abuse now
he's using it against the this uh victim
like for for example in my case in my
case I'm I was talking in general that
I'm going to go back to speak about my
case in my case all the implications of
this atrocity is being used against me
anything any movement, any moan, any
scream, any any action, any comment, any
expression is going to be used against
me.
That was the result of what I have
actually gone through.
This is crazy. This is disgusting.
So, um this is the whole idea.
Basically, it's temporary um use and
abuse through deception. It's sexual
exploitation through fraud. But we are
going to give it a few Islamic terms and
we are going to have the audacity to
claim that it's Islamically okay. And if
she opposes us and she's trying to hold
into her faith that she's been fighting
for all her life, giving dawa left,
right, and center and giving even my own
money to support their projects. Now I'm
being accused of being an enemy of
Islam. God knows what kind of actions I
have ever done. Like what? Like if you
believe in Islam, what kind of actions
do you even think that anyone could
possibly do to break it? You believe
Islam is unbreakable, right? You're
Muslim. You're a you are the head of
Dawa. Islam is unbreakable. So what do
you think? Like what do you mean like
enemy of Islam and she's f like so like
do you have the belief that people have
got something against Islam that could
break it? Then you're a kafir. What kind
of a Muslim are you?
So I am being accused of being these
things right and and and based on what
they are deriving these kind of
conclusions from a text some of those
texts I don't even recognize them you
know gathered throughout the past few
years so what is going on like bas what
is the process for you to establish that
this person is an apostate number one or
an enemy of Islam number two or a
mentally ill number Three, what is your
process? What is like what process do
you follow? Uh a tweet.
So um this is crazy like these things
are extremely crazy and disgusting. This
is beyond and these are not the things
that I have expected to be really honest
and frank. I didn't expect this. I
expected that there is going to be um a
correction from the scholars and this
story would have been closed far far far
long ago.
very long ago. It would have been closed
if the right actions would have been
taken.
>> Um, yeah. So, I'm thinking about uh how
this applies to what uh Muhammad Hijab
did, but it's like there are there are
levels of there are levels of bad. So,
on on the one hand, you could just not
be doing something wrong. You could do
the right thing. Um, but then let's
suppose you
uh convince a woman to marry you and you
you
say exactly what is going to happen and
then but you're lying about it. You're
making that up. You don't intend to
follow through on your agreement. You
could do something like that and realize
that what you're doing is wrong. Right?
So people can perform actions. This
would be anyone. This is Christians,
Muslims, anyone. You can do things that
you know are wrong and that you know God
would not approve of. So this would be
the level of you're doing something
wrong but you know that it's bad and you
know that God would not approve. Then it
would be kind of worse to be doing the
bad thing and to think that God approves
of it. So I'm doing the bad thing but
God is okay with it. Well now it's now
it's a problem. Now it's an even bigger
problem because now you've convinced
yourself that it's not even wrong. Even
though it's wrong. You're doing the same
thing that the wrong person did. you
just don't even know that it's wrong and
so you don't have much of an inclination
to change. And so, but even worse than
that, even worse than that would be
doing something that's wrong and
convincing yourself that God is okay
with it and teaching other people that
it's okay to do and teaching them how to
do it. Now, you're now you've got uh
you've convinced a bunch of people that
being bad is being good. being bad is
okay with God and God God gives the
thumbs up. And so
this is seriously dangerous stuff. Um if
you have influence over other people and
you influence them for evil, you were in
all kinds of you were in all kinds of
trouble um in life. But uh let's go
ahead and check out how Muhammad Oh, go
ahead.
>> I just wanted to add one extra comment.
There are so many women out there who
are going through these things. Some of
them came out and showed themselves out
on on social media. I'm sure if people
are going to search make researches
they're going to find so many stories
similar stories. So I'm trying to
include all the these scenarios and be
their voice
and u yeah and uh I think we did clarify
everything in regards to this point. So
this was not a miss marriage. this was
meant to be um sexual exploitation
and I was supposed to accept it and
people are questioning the degree of my
trauma
when he shows up to the hotel wearing a
ski mask and he says Allah says it's
okay to continue like this after he
promised my father and myself a
dignifying
making of a home and basically basically
this is what I assumed um like Islam
teaches. I've never had heard of
anything like this ever in my life. And
then he claims that Islam u approves of
it. We're going to keep meeting in
hotels wearing masks ever after. No
kids, no provision, no home. Let's keep
the in-laws out of the picture. And you
have to believe me when I tell you that
it's I have good intentions,
but I have zero intention of changing
this this scenario. It's going to
continue like this ever after. One of
the shu told me um in our my
conversation with him, why did you trust
him? Uh over a Zoom call. Then later on
in our conversation, he said, "Oh, okay.
And what if when he came with wearing a
mask to the hotel, maybe he could he
could have had good intentions
like and I was confused and I was losing
my mind. So I'm like okay so you are
blaming me for making a marriage and
trusting him right and making marriage
over zoom right although all the
credentials and and the position you
guys are putting him on then later on in
the conversation he I told him he's
showing with a mask he's showing his he
was like oh okay maybe he has good
intentions maybe he's going to change so
me as a woman in that scenario what do I
understand from this maybe he could
change he's saying he will never change
So what are you telling me when he says
he started he started defending him? Oh,
Muhammad hijab is is religious and he's
this and he maybe he's could change it
like you should think the best of of
people. So I told him are you asking me
to continue in that scenario? Is that
what you're asking me for? Like like so
in the beginning you said you shouldn't
trust him and now that he showed up with
a mask to the hotel and he's saying I
will never change this. I should trust
him.
So how does trust work?
Uh another sheh uh told he compared
Muhammad hijab with Abu Bakr the the
closest companion to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. So when I
brought up the story in front of him, he
said, "Oh, you know when people have
done great jobs for Islam, the sake of
Islam in times of prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, he brought up Abu
Bakr's story. He said some people
complained about him and the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam said, "Oh, leave
my companions alone. They have done
great job for Islam." I'm paraphrasing.
I'm like, what? No, you are
misinterpreting the text. No, the
prophet used to stand against falsehood,
right? You are a Muslim, you are a this
is what you have to say.
Um so there are there were a few
interactions with with scholars and the
shy I spoke to that created very big
issue for me and um
uh yeah um so I thought like uh it is
very important for me to share this and
I hope that there are going to be
lessons uh learned from this story.
>> Aisha
>> Oh go ahead. I just I just wanted to say
too, you were asking how can Muhammad
Hijab and Ali Dawa and all of these guys
focus on, you know, your mental health
quote unquote. Um, you being an
apostate, you know, not not believing in
Islam anymore. Like, why did they focus
on all of these things? I'm going to
tell you right now like one of the
components of this narcissistic
personality disorder that I would say
that Muhammad Hijab has is the fact that
in order for him to to do these horrible
things to you, you can't be a love
object of his. He has to divest, you
know, from you as a love object. And I
would say the reason they're focusing on
these things, Muhammad hijab especially,
there's paranoia there, right? When
people are paranoid, they're going to
basically focus on these little small
details about you and they're going to
make it something bigger than what it
is. It's basically they're they're in a
state of paranoia. They know that you
hold the truth about this situation and
you're coming out about it. So that's
why they're focusing on all these little
tiny details to try and stitch together
this bigger story about you that simply
isn't true.
Yeah. And just to highlight something,
he uh hijab confessed most of this
story, the details that I'm bringing out
in public to uh a lot of scholars like
so many of them knew a lot of about a
lot of details at that early stage when
she Muhammad was involved and they were
giving me answers about them. He did
this maybe because of that. he did this
maybe because of that. So, I've got some
names that I didn't want to mention for
one single reason and it's it's is very
traumatizing. It's sad is is disgusting.
It's bad. The reason I didn't want to
share these names because I noticed
sadly that every name that was brought
up came out with an oath by Allah or
false testimony against me to distance
themselves from the story. Ali and
Shehikh Muhammad. Although Sheikh
Muhammad has done great job for me. I
thank him at the early stages. He went
around. He collected information.
However, he was under a lot of pressure.
I feel bad for him. I do really feel bad
for him. But I am asking myself the
following question. What would have
happened to me if Salman wouldn't have
recorded those those phone calls with
the sheh?
What would have the scenario been? So
now we've got Sheikh Muhammad under
pressure, great pressure, disgusting
pressure.
Uh came out and gave those statements
and then Ali is coming out. In the
beginning, he showed up to me as if he's
trying to help. Then later on under
under hijab's pressure or whatever, he's
now coming out and and standing against
me and and saying you she's a liar and
and and attacking me. And basically this
is why I didn't want to bring out any
names. There are so many names that were
involved and I'm still reconsidering
mentioning those names.
>> Yeah. Aisha, you just uh you mentioned,
you know, what what would have happened
if if uh he hadn't been recording that
or this or that. Um, you look at all
these
all the ways this could have gone and
all the everything that had turned out
different. Like even if you hadn't if
you hadn't gotten in touch with Salman
um I mean like a bunch of things could
have happened differently and the
outcome would have been uh not in your
not in your favor.
I have to say I don't believe I don't
believe in Islam but in this whole
situation I believe God is on your side
because too many things turned out you
had so much you had so much against you
as we now know we didn't know how much
you had against you we thought okay you
got Muhammad Hijab and Ali Dawa against
you um that's a lot that's a lot these
are both you know uh million plus
subscriber channels and that's just on
YouTube but they also have uh influence
in in other areas but you just having
them against you would be very difficult
to overcome. Now, we know that there's a
an entire community of DA guys who have
channels and so on who have lots of
influence and they're all conspiring.
They're all conspiring
against you. And yet, they're the ones
who are all being exposed right now. And
uh every every everything that comes out
just shows that you are right and you've
been telling the truth all along. and
they've been lying all along. And so,
yeah, I think uh whatever whatever else
happens, whatever else happens, I
believe uh I believe I believe God is
helping you right now.
All right. So,
uh Aisha mentioned Muhammad Hijab trying
to defend all this from an Islamic
perspective.
Check this out here.
Now, this is a long post. Uh, anyone
jump in whenever you want to point
anything out. Uh, or if it's if it's too
much, just say at some point that's
enough or something like that. But let's
go ahead and see. Muhammad hijab in
action. In action. Because this is a man
who wants to defend everything he does
using um and use his religion to do
this. But Thaddius, what are we reading
here? Yeah. So this is a a tweet by
Muhammad Hijab shortly after the story
had broke and he was facing a lot of
criticism even from Muslims about
everything and the statements he'd made
in the past. So he posts this in which
he tries to clarify his position on
secret marriages or marriages with the
intention of divorce or muta as Shia
would call it even though as Sunnis are
like oh we don't do muta we don't do
muta but he's like all these things or
the these issues that are floating
around people are attacking for it he's
like okay I'm going to clarify my
position and he ends up contradicting
some of the things that he said on the
public record previously in his attempts
to, you know, clarify the situation,
which he's not involved in in any way,
right? Because he's still maintaining
that uh this is all a
a complete madeup attack on him. And uh
he's cla pretending that he's not making
any statements on it, that he's ignoring
it even though he's releasing videos on
an anonymous channel.
>> All right, so let's see what we've got
here. He says on secret marriages, I
guess I could do it in my hijab voice,
but uh marriages with the intention of
divorce and mutah uh jeritical
clarification.
This statement offers a clarification of
certain conceptual positions within
Islamic legal discourse, especially
those that were recently discussed in an
episode of the bitter truth. Following
that appearance, several of my remarks
were either misconstrued or reduced to
personal opinion. What was presented was
not a personal defense or prescriptive
argument, but a descriptive account of
legal perspectives grounded in the
classical tradition. This clarification
revisits those points with greater
precision and attention to juristic
structure. So, uh, already sounds like
people started using the clips to
criticize him and then make fun of his
position and so he has to clarify.
>> Yeah. Just one thing that I stood out to
me there. He said, "This is not a
personal or it wasn't a personal defense
when I went bitter."
>> Exactly.
>> Because we all interpreted it,
especially in light of the things coming
out as him finding justifications for
his own behavior. But no, no, no, no,
no. He says it wasn't. That's not what
he was doing.
>> He told on himself again.
>> Yes. This is I'm saying this for a
friend.
>> Yeah. So his post here, he's rectifying
and correcting uh like mainly the the
preachings that he was spreading.
And this is one of the conditions that I
did put forward to the board and the sh
I spoke to and to himself like you have
to come out and rectify and correct on
video and you have to put down the
videos that were mis um um misleading
the youth from an Islamic perspective.
Um so here he's claiming that he was
like innocently just talking from uh
like about jurist prudence and so on. No
his words in the past were extremely
specific. They were collected. They were
all building up an image of um like a
hit and run situation like using abuse
situation like the loopholes they were
crafted they were carefully selected and
they created a monster like a weapon to
destroy the lives of women. They were
very carefully selected his his his
preachings previously. So now in this
post after I did put a condition and and
asked the sh these are the things he has
to do in order for me to just stop
because I will not stop if these things
are not being corrected. So he did put
this post on his ex uh account which
obviously is not what I was asking for.
I was asking for him to come out on a
video, apologize about his action and
the destruction that he caused and admit
his mistakes and also make the the uh uh
corrections on video and put down all
the other videos that are misleading the
youth. So this attempt is just to shut
me down, just to ask me to stop. But
this is not what I was asking for. So
basically, I didn't.
>> Interesting. So this wasn't some random
post or wasn't uh even simply him trying
to defend himself because anyone who
watched the clips thought he was talking
about himself and then starts making fun
of uh making fun of him. And so this
isn't even just him trying to defend
himself against criticism. are saying
that this was him trying to keep you
quiet by, okay, she wants me to do this
and then she'll keep quiet, so let me go
ahead and do this. And you're saying,
no, this just this wasn't this wasn't
enough. This wasn't what I asked for.
>> Yes.
>> All right. So, Hijab says, "On so-called
secret marriages, the term secret
marriage is frequently misapplied. What
was discussed in the affforementioned
episode was not a marriage conducted in
legal secrecy, but one in which the
first wife was not notified or
consulted. According to the overwhelming
majority of jurists across the four
Sunni schools, such notification is not
a legal condition for the validity of a
subsequent nikah. This view reflects a
longestablished interpretive norm within
fick and should not be read as a
marginal or isolated opinion.
Islamic juristprudence however does not
function exclusively through abstract
validation. The classical legal
tradition distinguishes between the
theoretical derivation of a ruling and
its applied manifestation in context.
The latter is not an ethical addendum,
but an intrinsic part of legal
assessment. A practice that meets
technical conditions may still be
impermissible in application if it leads
to disproportionate harm or undermines
the objectives of the Sharia.
So, sounds like he's saying, "Hey, just
because you can defend something um
doesn't necessarily mean it's the
correct course of action because there
are other considerations like harm and
so on."
>> I kind of Yeah. So, I think what hijab
is saying is that you can't just go by
the technicalities.
You have to consider the whole
situation. Uh you can't just find
loopholes so to speak. uh you have to
consider what the consequences of your
actions are. So I guess my question to
him would be then um didn't your actions
lead to disproportionate harm? So are
you saying that you did something wrong?
Because if you are then just come out
and admit that. And if you're not saying
that, then I don't really understand
what your argument is exactly because
all of your argument was uh this is
technically allowed on the bitter truth,
right? On the bitter truth, you're like
this is technically allowed. You even
use terms like oh, you can you can give
black lies to your your wives. So, I'm
not really sure how this is anyway a
quote unquote clarification.
If you if you're now admitting you're
wrong, just say you're wrong.
>> It's just weird because everything I
hear from hijab when he's talking about
um rulings on various issues, everything
he says is it sounds like he just looks
for technicalities and what he can get
away with. So for him to be saying, hey,
that's not uh that's not the only
factor. You have to be considering the
the consequences or the harm that you're
causing. Uh yes, Thaddius is pointing
out, think about the harm that he caused
here. Is it is it uh disproportionate to
you know whatever he's using it to
justify? Uh but also like even
afterwards like hijab you trying to
cover things up and you lying to cover
these things up. Look at the damage
you're do. You're destroying
not just not just uh the situation
you're in, but you're you're ruining
things for all these other guys who are
being exposed now. and in various ways.
One, you know, this whole situation led
to Ali Dawa being exposed for um
whatever he was doing with his um secret
extra wife. But then you've got all
these guys in the DA community working
together, conspiring to discredit Aisha.
Like all of this is is just the result
of you trying to cover up what you did.
And I mean I just think about that if
you really believe that you need to pay
attention to the consequences of your
actions uh you might want to check out
the consequences of your actions.
But let's see here. He says uh
accordingly while such marriages may
fulfill the legal the uh the criteria of
legal form they may also cause severe
social emotional and familial damage. It
is on this basis not despite the law but
through it that many scholars would deem
them impermissible in practice.
Exceptional cases may arise in which
discretion or concealment becomes a
protective necessity, such as in
situations involving credible threats or
legal enttrapment, but these remain
marginal and must not be extrapolated
into general rulings.
>> I think this is he's still wrong about
this point.
>> Um like he's saying that there are some
cases where this is going to be um um
allowed. It's okay if you can just
please go back with the the slide trying
to go over what he just said in the last
paragraph. Right.
>> So he said exceptional cases may arise
in which discretion and concealment
becomes a protective necessity.
This is he's speaking about his own life
like his own situation, his own personal
situation. This is not okay
based on absolutely no cases in in in
any any cases. No, never. This type of
secrecy in this type of discretion and
this type of craziness and disgusting
actions could possibly be allowed. They
shouldn't. Like he's talking about
concealment to the point where the other
woman would be treated like a halal
prostitute just for the concealment,
right? Is like let's conceal. For the
concealment, no kids. For the
concealment, no home. For the
concealment, no in-laws. For the
concealment, shut up. For the
concealment, wear masks. For the
concealment, we go in separate. We come
out se Are you crazy?
>> Are you sick?
>> What? He said in some circumstances we
to avoid legal entrament.
Excuse me. If you've got issues uh in
your life, illegal entrapment, and I'm
talking in general, I'm talking
addressing men in general. If you got
issues in your life, fix them. Don't go
practice like like deception to uh to
other women and destroy their they
matter. They are human beings. They've
got a soul that you have destroyed.
you've got a life that you have
destroyed, right? So, do not practice
these things. There is no exceptions.
He says like like discretion and and
concealment and whatnot. Like if there
are women who do agree to these things
and they consent to these things, I
think that's a whole different topic
that we we're not talking about here. If
she's is a grown adult and she she she
um she gave permission to whatever kind
of craziness that's her, right?
But here if you are going to to involve
the the deception and the lies and
manipulation and the and the tactics and
all these things and then include these
kind of practices later on, this is
crazy.
And for women who do accept these kind
of things, I I personally do not think
it's halal. It's impermissible.
Marriage was meant to be the making of a
family, a home, companionship, right,
for the rest of of the life of the two.
Like in in in in Islam, we've got
polygamy. That is something that we are
not discussing here. I know you guys
that you don't understand that, you
don't accept it probably. But like in
the concept of polygamy even in polygamy
there has to be a home care um like like
a human being who cares of his family
big family right in a home children
everybody knows about everything.
So, um this secrecy uh details I I had
to to to make a a last comment about it
because some people uh were um
commenting and saying you didn't want to
let his wife know. In Islam, I wasn't
doing something wrong or bad in order
for me to go and let her know. Even his
previous second wife, she did let her
know when things went wrong between her
and him. when the the the the
relationship probably broke up or
whatever the situation was and then she
was like okay this is what I'm going to
go and do like if there is a polygamy
polygamous marriage and the man says
please it's going to be up to me to
inform my other wife that is none of the
business of the other wife the other
women in his in his household so like
you understand because like in order for
me to go and say oh okay I have to go
and disclose this information to his
other wife.
This is as if I am inside thinking that
what's this the making of this family is
wrong you know like it's has disgusting
is wrong whatever
where where it's not right so when a
husband tell his second wife that it's
going to be up to me to inform my first
wife
I don't think I don't understand why I'm
being criticized about that so He said,
"Do not let her know." The other second
wife did let her know. Everything broke
down. Please leave that to me. That's
all what it is. So, I think this is this
is this detail should have been uh
included in this section because this is
a clarification that so many people
needed to hear.
>> And so, we have on marriages with the
intention of divorce.
A similar jeritical structure applies to
the case of marriages contracted with a
concealed intention to divorce. This
practice is distinct from MUTA where
both parties explicitly stipulate a time
limit. Here only one party privately
intends to end the marriage after
fulfilling a specific goal.
The vast majority of Sunni jurists
including al- Shafi Iben Kurama and Ib
Tamia held that such an intention does
not affect the formal validity of the
marriage provided its contractual
elements are met. However, jurists such
as Al Azai viewed this act as
impermissible, associating it with
deception and likening it in effect to
MUT. Yes, I would agree with the latter.
There does sound like deception and
similar to muta. Uh the significance of
the tussle tenzel distinction again
becomes evident even when a con even
when a contract is valid in form its
permissibility in application may shift
based on the presence of deception,
breach of trust or social harm. In such
cases, the internal intention, though
technically irrelevant to the validity
of the contract, may contribute to its
impermissibility.
In practice, the legal tradition
provides a mechanism for evaluating not
only actions, but also their
consequences and surrounding conditions.
Some jurists observed that women under
certain legal formulations may seek
divorce for reasons of personal
dissatisfaction. However, such
observations do not justify intentional
concealment by either spouse. They
merely reflect the tradition's
recognition that internal motivations
exist and must be legally interpreted
when they become operative in social
reality.
So it seems to be the same thing here.
He's saying that, you know, technically
speaking, if you go by the letter of the
law, you're allowed to marry with
intention of divorce. But if you
consider all of the circumstances and
you consider what this will actually do
to women and what this will actually do
to the the families involved and
everything, then in practice, it
generally will become impermissible.
But again, when he's going on the bitter
truth, right, he's basically just
saying, "Nope, that this is allowed."
Did you Did you guys know that this is
allowed?
>> So, he is coming out and in a sense
correcting his previous teachings,
although he's pretending that he's just
clarifying things. He's not actually
admitting that he was intentionally
teaching things that are wrong.
On the question of mutah, in subsequent
critiques, it has been claimed that
certain Sunni practices such as misar or
marriage with the intent to divorce are
functionally ingu indistinguishable from
mutah and that the Sunni critique of
muta is thereby undermined. This
comparison may have some merit when
analyzing consequences alone,
particularly in cases where such
practices are abused. However, this
perspective neglects the legal
distinction in structure, intent, and
textual basis. According to the
overwhelming majority of Sunni jurists,
MUT was explicitly abregated. Its
prohibition is not derived from a
consequentialist framework, but from
scriptural evidence and juristic
methodology. Its legal impermissibility
rests on the fact of its abrogation,
not solely on its outcomes. That said,
the tradition also acknowledges that any
form mut or otherwise that leads to
systematic harm may through the
principle of masada be reassessed at the
level of application. The central
disagreements between Sunni and Shia
traditions lie elsewhere. The divergence
concerns core theological principles
such as the infallibility of the imams,
the nature of religious authority, and
the integrity of the Quranic text. While
Mutah remains a significant point of
legal divergence, it does not constitute
the doctrinal foundation of that
divergence.
So his conclusion here, Islamic Jewish
prudence cannot be reduced to a binary
of legality and morality. It is a
tradition that integrates abstract legal
reasoning with contextual application.
The tassel of a ruling may yield a
particular outcome in theory, but its
tanzil shaped by circumstances,
consequences, and ethical concerns may
revise or restrict that ruling in
practice. This is not an innovation, but
a foundational feature of the legal
method. My remarks in bitter truth were
an attempt to present this structure
briefly and in good faith. They were not
endorsements of any specific practice,
nor were they personal claims. wants to
stress that these were not personal
claims. If those comments were
misunderstood, then the fault lies not
in the tradition, but in the failure to
appreciate its depth and complexity. The
aim here is simply to reaffirm the
interpretive integrity of that tradition
and the necessity of distinguishing
between abstract rulings and their
applied form.
Yeah, I'm calling cap on this being
presented in good faith on bitter truth.
uh every word he's saying is about
technicalities on that program. He
seemed to be arguing the exact opposite
that if we can find technical reasons
why we can do something then it's
permissible for us to do it. I'm glad
that he now has adopted the position
that Aisha and many other Muslims have
that the law is is not just about the
letter of the law but it's about the
spirit and intent as well. But that's
not what he was arguing on that program.
He's being very disingenuous when he's
saying that is the case. Basically, he
got called out and now he says, "Okay,
I'm going to this this is very
important. That's why I'm not going to
make a video about it. That's why I'm
not going to put it on my YouTube
channel. I'm just going to make a very
long tweet." And based on the nature of
Twitter, people are almost certainly not
going to read it for the most part.
>> This was basically like word salad. So
many words for saying like I did
something and I'm doing damage control
now. I'm making a a poor attempt at
damage control.
Yeah. And this is why that post doesn't
serve the purpose. That was not the
purpose. The purpose was to to um um
retract the damage the great damage that
you have um destruction that you have
created in in the land basically.
And therefore it should have been
broadcasted and all the false other uh
teachings should have been uh retracted
and pulled off the internet and you
should have come out with an apology to
the women who have been abused based on
those teachings.
>> All right. Now let's go ahead and uh
compare what hijab said there with some
clips from
the bitter truth
>> from the brother side. Lots of men are
married to women who do not wear hijab,
right? And then later on down the line,
it's like, "Put your hijab on."
>> Okay. So, the sister's like, "Hold on,
you wasn't like this in the beginning."
So, why all of a sudden there is like
this?
>> So, what can he do?
>> No, they have to if he if he's if he's
tolerating. Yeah.
>> He can say, "Look, I can I'll give you 6
months." There only two things I can see
happening.
>> But we're talking about reasons for the
marriage breaking down, right? So, I'm
saying that potentially
a man leaving a woman and saying, "Look,
you're being disobedient. You're not
practicing the way I want you to." But
I'm saying in the beginning, right, you
compromised on that thing. So,
>> so what I mean, so I don't understand
the issue here. So, he wants this now.
She's not doing it.
>> But it needs to divorce ultimately.
Exactly.
>> But no, no, no. What I'm saying is I get
me. But what I'm saying to you is
>> for me, divorce is not as bad as her not
put hijab on anyway.
what's going on here.
>> So, what we've got here, sorry, I'm just
make a quick comment about this. So,
what we've got here is um he's changing
his position that he uh put in the
bitter truth previously, which was like
you have to keep your word. You have to
respect your word. If you agree in
something and you sign on something, you
have um like um contract on something,
you have to follow it as a man. But here
he's going like he can do whatever he
feels like doing like like listen
divorce has to be like so he's creating
an environment
like it's a natural reflex after his
actions. He's trying to create an
environment that shows that divorce is
okay regardless of the the the amount of
damage it could possibly create on the
women. Like you marriage has to be an
easy affair. Like divorce has to be an
easy affair. He can come, he can go, he
can divorce, he can agree, he can
disagree, he can promise, he can break
his promise. Like he can do whatever
he's he wants as long as he he's not uh
committing adultery and he's not
watching pornography.
And uh even in this uh even in this
short clip right here um it sounded like
the sounded like the issue was uh
suppose
uh a a man marries a woman and he tells
her it's fine if she doesn't want to
wear the hijab but then after they get
married he says no now I want you to
wear the hijab and so they're asking him
about that and he's like well you know
if if that's what he wants that's what
he wants and the alternative is divorce.
And and so that that sounds similar that
sounds similar to what he did with you.
Although it doesn't sound like he
changed his mind. It sounds like this
was his plan all along. But after you're
after you get married, then it's okay.
Now here's how it's going to be. And the
al the only alternative is divorce. But
he's the one who put you in that entire
position to begin with and was intending
to do so in order to kind of keep you in
that position.
So yeah, sounds like he's defending the
idea.
>> Yeah, absolutely. This was the plan uh
based on what I have not uh experienced
because he had a a back and forth
previous to the nikah that I couldn't
understand. He was putting himself
forward on the phone because we had
phone calls but at the same time putting
forward his friends that confused me and
uh he was like um like first in the end
was the first uh proposal where he spoke
to my father and then he retracted and
he didn't give much explanations. So all
those actions and he told me I'm trying
to do what is best for you and I was
confused. If you are a good man from an
Islamic perspective and it's polygamy
from an Isla Is Islamic perspective. So
why is abuse even brought up on the
table if you are a Muslim and you are
going to keep your word and you are
going to take very good care of your
family, your big family.
So therefore, there are things that were
in hiding from the get-go that have
created that situation of going back and
forth and hesitance in in getting the
marriage done and like so these things
were in his head and it was
orchestrated. It was pre-planned
and Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the the lady there in blue
there asked uh you know
A man and a woman they get married they
have an agreement it happens to be
around hijab but in principle it could
be anything and then the man says
something decides something else how is
this right and hijab's response is so
what he changed his mind
>> he can and if she doesn't like that she
can get a divorce those are the options
right so they had an agreement in this
case it was around hijab and man changes
his mind oh Well, you you got two
options. You can do what he says or you
can get a divorce, which makes your
contract or your terms or your agreement
before the marriage basically
meaningless because the man has
unlimited authority to change it in
whatever way he wants at any time
according to hijab.
>> All right. And now we have another clip
from the bitter truth Muhammad hijab on
changing marriage terms. Or let's say
for example you're not married but
you're addicted to pornography you're
not lowering your gaze you're not doing
nothing that Islam is saying you're
distracted you're you know you're
actually still in pain from your pro
whatever it may be right which are the
two situations better for me even if I'm
not going to say like these scholars who
say marriage with the intention of
divorce they actually mention with the
intention of divorce right I'm not going
to say go into any marriage I agree with
I mean with anyone right do not go into
any marriage with the intention of
divorce. But what if you go into a
marriage and say the following with the
following intention? I'm going to go
into this marriage. I'm going to test
the waters. I don't know if I'm going to
be with this woman for the rest of my
life or not. How about that? How?
Because that intention for me is is
better than being going into like
effectively pornography, addiction or
zena, which are the two big ailments of
time.
>> So yeah, the two clips actually got out
of order. This one is on uh marriage
with the intention divorce. The one we
just watched was on changing terms. But
what his job is saying is, well, you got
some options, right? You got some
options in the modern world. You could
like actually fall in love with a woman
and commit your life to her. But, you
know, that's probably not going to
happen. So, it if if that's not the
case, then you got two options. You can
look at pornography, you can commit
adultery, or you know, you can just
enter into a marriage and say it may
work, it may not. You know, we might get
divorced after a week. basically saying
that marriage is just the exact same
thing as pornography, addiction or
adultery, but we signed a legal contract
and that's much better now is the idea
here. So he says if you if you have if
you marry someone with the intent to
divorce just like I married someone who
I knew had the intent to divorce over a
Zoom call or a WhatsApp call. Uh that's
fine. That's still better. That's still
better than having the same sexual
relationship outside of marriage. So,
it's all good. It might not be ideal,
but it's okay because it's better than
the alternative. That's what he's
saying.
>> And he's saying he's talking about
testing the waters.
>> He's talking about testing the waters.
And hey, you know, maybe I'm not even
intending to uh marrying and then
intending to divorce, but maybe I'm
understanding that I'll marry I'll marry
her and if she's everything you know
that I tell her to be, then maybe I'll
stick with her and uh if I start telling
her what to do and she doesn't listen,
then you know,
well,
I tested the waters and uh now it's now
it's divorce. Anyway, what were we
saying? Aisha.
>> Yeah. So, I was saying uh notice here
that from hijab's pers uh perspective,
from his speeches, he only cares about
men.
I don't know if anyone is capable of of
of noticing this. Like, who who cares?
Like, he's literally as if he's saying,
"Who cares?" Like, he doesn't see the
woman at all. Like whether you just want
to try her, you whether you just want to
use her and and let her ditch her,
whether you like like who cares? Like
who are you? Where are your kids? Where
is your life? Where is your youth? We've
already stigmatized you. And so
regardless of what happens to you, you
are like you're damaged. Like you're
unworthy of nothing. So whatever we do
of you does not matter. So even if I'm
going to marry you and divorce you,
regardless of what my intentions are,
regardless of how I view marriage,
regardless of whatever I do of you, it
does not matter. You know, as soon as
I'm going to divorce, you can go to
hell. Go kill yourself. Like he said in
his text messages on WhatsApp, we don't
care if you kill yourself. Go yourself.
You are divorced twice. We've
stigmatized you in the the community as
divorces are have no value. Now you can
go and deal with your trauma, deal with
your mental health, and we're going to
follow you with our fingertips to
criticize you about your trauma, about
your mental health that we have caused
you to go through. Any action you go
ahead and do is you're going to be
criticized.
And like that's all it speaks for on
behalf of men. He only sees men and
women are nothing. They are non-existent
in these speeches.
So like in in terms of what I have gone
through personally,
it was like either you're going to agree
to these terms or it's a divorce. And I
told I went through I went for the
divorce straight away. He told me this
is a divorce that was initiated by you.
This is what he told me. He told me the
divorce was initiated by you. I it's not
it's not initiated by me. So if you want
me to take you back, just agree to my
terms.
Like imagine like so I had this
conversation with him you know I had
this you can still come back if you
agree to what I want from you which is
just to be a halal prostitute.
>> Wow.
>> You know um
>> he's established a clear sorry
>> go ahead.
>> Yeah. I know. So there are so many women
are going through these things and like
so these are the this is the influence
that the youth are getting.
He's established a clear pattern here
three times I would argue his first wife
he married her had an entire family with
her from what I understand and then he
decided to take a second wife and
discarded her and also by taking a
second wife and you know not informing
his first wife you're showing your first
wife is just a tool she's a tool to get
whatever you want out of her you know
you're getting the family you're
probably some structure there. And then
he gets the second wife, discards her.
Then he gets you and discards you. Like
women, he he's developed a pattern of
showing that he uses women as tools.
Something to use, get what he wants,
discard.
>> Yeah. And again, the serious issue, the
issue that makes it more serious is that
he has massive influence over
other people, um, especially young
Muslims. And you know, it's similar to
the situation with Andrew Tate. Uh
Andrew Tate was influencing a lot of
young men and giving them some very bad
ideas about how to treat women. And
Sister Aisha is right. He seems to
everything he's saying is just it's not
just for him. It's how men can
get away with treating women. And there
there never seems to be the slightest
concern about the well-being or the good
of the women.
creepy stuff.
But
let's go ahead.
>> Um, I just wanted to add one extra point
really quick. Like what you said here,
what you're pointing at here is even
worse than than Andrew Tate. By the way,
this what this is what made me talk
because Andrew Tate is not he's not
graduate from Alazar.
Andrew Tate doesn't have like PhDs or
whatever master degrees and Islamic
studies or whatnot. David would like um
Andrew Tate Andrew Tate does not like he
doesn't have people scholars from the
Middle East sit at his feet while he's
giving a speech. Andrew Tate is not a
Muslim clergy. He's not he's not um
advertised as a as the head of the da.
So Muhammad Hijab's actions and his
influence is even worse is way much more
dangerous
>> and that's why he's being exposed right
now. Um Thaddius we have the issue of
secrecy coming up with looks like some
back and forth some back and forth.
>> We have the Ali Dawa and Muhammad hijab
view and then uh knowledge north
responding. So, we ready to go through
these?
>> Yep. Let's do it. See what we got here.
>> These women here are actually
characterizing an institution with the
most negative superlatives, um, most
negative adjectives, with with most
horrible of context. Hijab then has the
audacity to cite this ayah as if he is
championing the justice between wives it
prescribes. He is not. He is advocating
secret sex marriages which he knows will
end in broken hearts and broken homes
the moment the sidewife demands her fair
and god-given equal rights.
>> Sorry. Sorry to say this,
>> but it does seem to be an inad issue, a
submission issue, and it's the Islam
issue. M
>> it's it's an issue of submission and
iman.
>> If you truly believe in Allah subhana wa
tala and you believe in his uh rulings,
I'm sorry to say and you and you have
full faith in that and you did what
Allah said when he said
coming to Islam altogether.
>> Okay, good.
>> You cannot describe the situation of
living in a marriage which potentially
you be getting all your rights as a
first wife
>> in such traumatic fashion.
So where does a woman or a man have to
submit to lying and deceit in the name
of religion?
>> Allah has stipulated that if the man
wants to go and do that he does it in
the right way by honoring her speaking
to her father doing the marriage giving
a mah announcing the marriage not hidden
honoring her speaking to her father
announcing the marriage not hidden.
>> Oopsie that.
Yeah. So this whole clip is from
knowledge north video. Obviously he's
clipped something from a conversation of
Ali Dawa and Muhammad Hijab and they're
discussing a a clip that was on a uh
show of a bunch of Muslim women talking
about issues. I forget exactly it's
something like tea time or something
like that is the name of it but
basically they discuss sensitive issues
and hijab took offense to this. he took
offense to the way they talked in that
program and so he felt he needed to do a
video calling them out on what they were
saying in that and uh comes on here
calls them out and knowledge north is
like this is pattern right that he's
doing for things far far worse they may
have said a few things in poor taste or
you know used some inappropriate
language or something along those lines
but they weren't wrong about anything
Islamically and then he's coming on here
and saying the these women are on the
verge of apostasizing from Islam because
they they said a few words he doesn't
like and then Ali Dawa is like you got
to do things in the right way and
contradicting the actual actions of
Muhammad Job.
>> Yeah. And then he blurts out, yeah, not
hidden. North hidden.
>> Oopsie.
It's funny because if I had to if I had
to put one word after Ali Dawa said
that, I would have put oopsy. And that's
what knowledge north did.
All right. So uh knowledge north is
going to uh continue with this issue of
secrecy and has a different view from
Muhammad hijab.
>> The whole point of having witnesses is
for public accountability to protect the
couple from being suspected of sexual
impropriy.
This is why in the maliki mab while the
two just witnesses are recommended their
presence is not a strict condition
provided the marriage is publicized in
the community just as the companions
would spread news of a marriage in
compliance with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's order to
>> announce the marriage.
>> But when the witnesses are sworn to
secrecy then the msar wife assumes the
role of a mistress in an extrammarital
affair. any comments?
>> Um, so what I was saying is like this is
something that was brought up. Uh, we
had this conversation and I told him
we're going to get slandered.
So what would the people think of
Muslims? Is this what Muslims do? They
go to hotels wearing ma like wearing
masks like what is this? He said you
should like so his reaction um built up
an extra reason for for me to come out
of from the marriage and he was like you
shouldn't worry and like so I realized
like you don't worry if your wife gets
slandered in the community
>> she's going around in hotels
and you don't mind if you get slandered
okay if this is really you have good
intentions this is real relationship
although it's clearly not Um, so how are
you going to break this down to your
children when they grow up? After a few
years, they become teenagers and they
find out that their parents are going to
hotels.
>> My child and his children.
Um, so these are things that are
extremely problematic and there were a
lot of men that were following on his
footsteps.
>> Yeah,
>> sister very well there. Go ahead,
>> sister Aisha. I have a question about
the whole secrecy behind all of this.
So, did Muhammad Hijab say anything to
you like, you know, not to tell people
you got married, like don't tell your
friends or anybody in the community? Did
he say anything to you about like
deleting text messages? Like, did he try
to like kind of convince you to maintain
this level of secrecy that he wanted
like on your end?
So the whole situation was that because
I am his neighbor, as soon as I move out
from my property, we're going to have
our own children. The neighbors know
that we are married because he's coming
home obviously. And this is the the only
format according to me, the only format
of a marriage in Islam. There is no you
can't keep going around like animals to
hotels. It doesn't work like that.
You're going to be you're here to make a
family. You have kids. You're bringing
the grocery whether it's two women,
three, four polygamy. Okay. Uh yeah, we
we believe in it. Okay. If you are
Muslims, but in what way? In which way?
In this way, I reject you and I reject
your version of Islam. So now, now in
regards to this secrecy, it was only in
regards to his other wife. Try that. It
wouldn't come from you, please.
leave me to break break this news to
her. So if it is to go and tell your
friends and your friends we are in the
comm like in the masjid or the mosque or
whatever just don't spread the news.
Don't go to the mosque and go like oh
and I I was like why would I need to do
that? If we're going to have our home
this is marriage like this is not a
game. We're not teenagers. If you're
going to speak to my family, you're
going to have a home or have children
and you are providing for the family and
wherever you would like to live. If you
want to take your time to break the news
down to your other wives, it's fine.
Like
it's okay. You can do that on your own
times. But this type of secrecy where
he's going around wearing mask, it's
something that he never brought up to
me. He never got my agreement on this
ever. I never agreed that we are going
to be hiding like
disgusting. It's extremely disgusting
that you go around and you have the
audacity to say that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala allowed you to do these things.
It's permissible in Islam. I am going to
be here to fight you against this.
All right, let's check out Ibent Tia
what he has to say.
As for a secret marriage, it is akin to
the marriage of prostitutes.
>> Prostitute.
>> Allah the exalted said, "Chasted women,
not those who commit fornication or take
them as lovers. So secret marriage is
akin to the practice of those who have
secret lovers.
So I guess hijab the idea here is hijab
has ibentia going against him.
Yeah. Very important figure in Islam
there. So very good source by knowledge
citing this that it's not just his
opinion,
>> right? He said it was his opinion that
it was having taking a secret wife was
like taking a mistress. But then you got
Iban Tama saying the same thing and
actually going further and saying that
she's just a prostitute if that's the
way you're going to treat her. And I
would agree practically speaking that is
indeed what you're doing in that
scenario right
>> not the scenario Aisha agreed to but the
scenario that Muhammad hijab wanted
where it would remain complete secret
for all time.
Uh
>> all right now we have knowledge north
again
>> swearing the witnesses and the wi to
secrecy is the only shoe where to keep
the marriage hidden from the public
indefinitely and that would be haram.
Unsurprisingly, those most vulnerable to
such secret marriages are reverts.
Because revert sisters ordinarily won't
have a Muslim father as their natural
guardian or believing brothers and
uncles and such close Muslim male
relatives who could represent and
protect them and fight their corner for
them against abusive, oppressive and
manipulative husbands or one hit wonder
handpicked by the groom. And
>> and uh just wanted to point out that we
have heard Muhammad hijab explaining uh
in his words how revert women take it
best and knowledge north gave why that
might be
of the evils that result from secret
marriages are too many and often tragic.
There was a revert sister with a child
who was in a secret marriage long term
and she actually passed away and so did
her child in a car crash.
>> Yeah. And the husband refused to
take responsibility for the funeral
despite the sister having a family who
would not have gave her a a janaza under
the Sharia. He refused to take
responsibility for the funeral of his
wife or his son because he didn't want
his first wife and his first wife's
family to find out.
>> Whoa. So, that was on the uh that was on
the consequences of secret marriages. So
sounded like sounded like she was saying
there was a woman she converted to
Islam, got married, then she's in a car
crash, but since since it was a secret
marriage, her husband didn't want to
take responsibility for it and her
family wasn't going to give her her
family was non-Muslim, so they weren't
giving her an Islamic burial. And so by
him not taking not uh not saying he's
married to her, she didn't have an
Islamic burial because he was
>> Yeah. Which which is kind of a big deal,
right? Kind of a big deal that the the
bodies won't be properly buried. Uh he
but he doesn't care, right? What he
cares about is keeping it a secret from
his first wife. So they they had a
long-term relationship. I I don't know
what that means exactly, but it wasn't,
you know, a one night stand situation.
and they had a long-term relationship
where he kept the marriage secret long
term and then they got in a car crash.
The his second wife and the child they
had together got in a car crash. They
both died. And he's like, "Well, my
first wife can't find out about that
secret marriage. So, she's just out of
luck. Her family's not going to provide
her a proper Islamic burial." Oh, well,
she doesn't get a primary proper Islamic
burial.
>> Don't care. Don't care as long as it
doesn't affect me. And huh, who does
that sound like?
You know, that's pretty pathetic and sad
that these secret marriages, even like
in an example like that, even in death,
it's like, what do you do with her body?
Well, I'm not going to take care of it.
And whatever her family does, they do,
they do. They bury her however they
want, or cremate her even, which isn't
allowed in Islam. You know, it's just
she's just trash. Gone. Goodbye. They
don't care.
>> That's pretty wild. That's pretty wild
stuff. All right. Any other comments on
this before we go into a clip of
Muhammad hijab?
Go ahead.
>> Yeah, I was just going to say that um
this is why uh the scholars have to
correct these things. We would like I'm
just asking please come out explain to
us you understand
explain to me uh answer me explain to me
clarify to me y if I'm horrible call me
to Islam you know I am still Muslim I'm
learning I'm I'm going crazy I'm going
crazy come out help me explain these
things these consequences these
implications these wrongdoings these the
these uh like corruption in the land.
Explain to me, explain to us, all of us,
I mean the Muslim uh community, explain
to us as Muslims, as women, come out and
explain to us. Um because we can hear
clearly see the implications of these
actions at so many levels and there are
millions of other stories and this is
their job. Their job is to clarify the
real version of Islam.
And if they don't, then we're just going
to be stuck with the ideas of da guys
like Daniel
and Muhammad Hijab. Let's see what
they've got to say.
Now, what you have to see what is your
artillery if you're trying to control
the situation. You have you have you
have
you have
you have polygamy which can be done is
not as a punishment or anything but just
it can be done that you
>> you don't have those things in your
artillery that's why I'm
>> the legal system the legal system has
made all of these options uh illegal
like they're actually illegal or they
>> decide I'm not going to have sex with my
wife they're going to come and arrest
you for example
>> no she'll she'll accuse you of abuse as
well and when she divorces says you
she'll get all your property, she'll get
custody of the kids.
>> Then then American Muslims shouldn't get
married by the British law by the sorry
the American law.
>> It doesn't matter.
>> Everyone catch what he just said right
there. So this this is the idea. If
you're if you're if you get married
according to the American law, in other
words, it's done um it's done legally.
The marriage is done legally in the
United States of America. Then
when you get a divorce, then she's going
to be able to seek legal recourse
against you. And hijab there is saying
then don't do it. Don't do it through
the legal system.
>> Interesting. Let's let him continue
here.
>> If you're doing even if you just do your
uh legally obligated to these things,
you're still accountable to the Yeah.
There's no distinction. How would you
prove that you done the
>> every everyone catch this? I don't want
to I don't want to keep interrupting,
but I want people to catch what he's
saying here. So Daniel Hakeiku brings
up, well, even if you just do uh a
marriage in the moss, she'll be able to
show that you guys were married and
hijab saying, well, how's she going to
prove it? So what's this mean? Because
he already has it in his mind that I'm
the guy who's going to pick handpick the
witnesses who are my friends who will
lie for me. And so how is she going to
prove anything to anyone? What are we
going to she going to walk into court
and they're going to say she going to
say, "Hey, we're married." And the judge
is going to say, "Okay, where's the uh
you know, where's the marriage
certificate?" All this. Oh, I don't have
any of that stuff. Um, okay. Where are
the witnesses? No, they all agree with
him. He's saying, "How are you going to
prove it?" So, he's actually, I mean,
keep in mind, this would have been a man
who married a woman, then they divorced,
then she tries to prove that they're
married. And this is Muhammad Hijab from
a couple years ago saying, "If you're
willing to lie, how is she going to
prove anything?
It it it's so weird that the DAWA guys,
much like Andrew Tate, Andrew Tate said
he was doing all these things for years
and then once people actually accuse him
of doing it and he finds out it's
illegal, then it's no, I never did that
stuff. And here you have hijab talking
about all this stuff, talking about all
this stuff that's going on. And then all
this stuff that he's been defending for
years as soon as it's pointed out, hey,
that's what that's what you're doing.
You're lying about your marriage just
like you taught was okay to do. Lie
about being married. Now you're doing
it. I would never do that. No, she must
be the one who's lying. I haven't seen
her defend lying. I've seen you do I've
seen you defend lying pretty much almost
every video clip I've ever seen of you
is you defending lying for something.
>> And the whole conversation here is about
so hijab says like you got tools, you
can manipulate women, right? that that's
the whole context of the conversation is
you got all these tools you can uh use
against your wives who you know want to
be treated as decent human beings or
whatever and and Daniel's like well the
problem is here in America you don't
have those tools because the the legal
system has set up protections for
women's and hijab is like okay well
here's how you get around the legal
system right so they're conspiring on
how to get around American laws set up
to for the protection of women and yet
somehow this is, you know, Islamically
good, right? That the whole thing is
they're complaining about how the laws
are against Islam.
>> And this is,
>> you know, too.
>> Oh, go ahead.
>> You know, too, this is, you know, we're
talking about, you know, this secret
short-term marriage type of thing, but
what about these secret marriages that
are maintained for years? There's secret
children, there's a secret life,
everything like that. And if there's no
legal marriage, you know, that's also
another way to strip women of their
rights and to, you know, basically screw
them over by just having this type of
arrangement.
>> Yeah. And uh my goodness, it's again,
it's it's just amazing to me that
sitting here defending all this stuff
and then he actually does it
and then his followers don't believe
don't
the for for the followers who are still
on his side who think that he didn't do
this.
We have video of him saying that's
exactly what someone should do. So it is
an interesting situation where he does
seem to view Islam. This is his view of
Islam. Islam is one big set of tools on
how I can how I can abuse women. And
then he's horrified to think that oh in
some places women will actually have
tools to avoid being treated like this.
And so, how do you remove that from the
women so that we're the only ones who
who emerge victorious in these
situations? And everyone else, we can do
whatever we want to them and there's
nothing they can do about it. And we
want we want to keep women there. So,
>> do not acknowledge any of this that
you're that we're actually doing. This
is wild stuff. But let's let him
continue here.
>> Uh, how would you prove that you're
married?
>> Yeah. No, all she has to go is go to
court and say, "Yeah, he married me in
the masid or she he married me according
to Islamic law." And that that'll
actually count against you because the
judge will say that, "Oh, using religion
to manipulate her."
>> I wish it was I wish it were that easy.
But unfortunately,
>> I don't know. I think that I don't know
if it's every state is as doom gloom as
you're making it out. Most states
actually have common law marriage and in
according to common law marriage just
the fact that you have been living
together regardless is if of their anah
or marriage you count as a married
couple and you can be divorced and you
can
>> okay in that case then the brothers
should put their assets and their things
in other people's names they should put
>> oh my god
>> now you're getting this so so guys
>> I think um I think wait sorry let me
just add this point here I think what he
should have said that there because he
told them if he they have been living
together then they are counted as
married couples
and according to what I I have
experienced that's exactly what he was
trying to avoid.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, just one, it's him
trying to make it so that the woman can
never prove that she's been married. And
on the chance that she can prove that
somehow, even when he's lying, she
somehow proves it. Hey, make sure your
stuff is in other people's names so that
there's a lot of secrecy for this guy.
Everything is everything is secret and
deception and lying and covering things
up and
and
>> Sister Aisha, Sister Aisha, I have
another question. I think maybe it was
one of Salman's videos or somewhere
else. Maybe it was in Thaddius's video
about with you. Did you pay for the
hotels for for you and Muhammad Hijab?
And was that like an attempt to not have
anything traceable on his credit card or
anything like that?
Yeah, that's a very good question. Um,
so we are talking here about a a stage
in the relationship where everything
according to me was going to move to the
right direction. Right? So I wasn't
thinking through a lot. He asks me to do
something. It's the early stages of the
marriage. I do them. So now later on
after everything happened I realized
that he was trying to avoid to be traced
even financially.
So what he did he asked me to make the
payment and sent the money through the
witnesses.
So all of that. So uh in other words to
meet at a hotel and pay for the hotel he
would have the money sent to you through
other parties uh to we we call that we
call that avoiding a paper trail so that
there's no paper records of uh of what
someone is doing. So so it's basically
at the time you didn't think there you
didn't spot any you weren't thinking oh
he's got some scam going on or he's
planning something but later on when you
look back at it it's like oh that's what
he was doing. He was trying to he was
trying to avoid leaving any records.
>> Yes.
>> Interesting fellow. Interesting fellow
here. Uh got a few more seconds of this.
Let's see.
>> In that case, the brothers need to be
savvy with that. There's obviously a way
out there. I'm I'm not a tax expert or
you know inheritance expert or something
like that or trust other people. There's
no doubt. But you have to have a couple
of guys that in your life that you trust
and that you give them a part of your
company this and that. So you can avoid
this nonsense because in Islam and
Muslim women need to understand this is
completely haram to take 50% of a man's
earnings. You have no right to take this
money. It's a theft. You are stealing
his you are a leech. How dare you take
his money. So there's no reason for you
to take his money like that. But to be
fair like alhamdulillah I actually
married my wife by the law. Yeah. I
trust alhamdulillah. You know she's
she's all good. But I've also got things
in place.
>> She can't trust me.
>> So these are the kind of magic.
>> Oh everyone catch that. But I've also
got things in place, which means I also
have
>> other women that I'm married to. And
they then he smiles and they all start
laughing. Uh let me play that little
part again.
>> Also got things in place. And so that
these are the kind of magic
these are these are the kind of things
that you know uh we all have to all have
to do.
>> Everyone got that.
>> All right.
>> Champion of Dawe here.
>> Yeah. So that's Muhammad Hijab and
Daniel Hikachu on how to trick people
about whether you've been married and uh
even if she can prove it, how to avoid
paying her afterwards uh in a divorce
settlement.
All right, so what we have left are some
clips from Knowledge North who does not
approve of this.
>> Related to the issue of divorce is that
of the in-laws.
>> Most of the marriages break because of
the in-laws. Let's just not add more
in-laws in the picture.
>> Allegedly, that's what Hijab said.
Allegedly. But whether or not one
accepts the lady's testimony, it's
hardly a stretch to suspect that the man
who is a fan of a nostrings nikah will
want to cut out his in-laws.
Furthermore, it's more than reasonable
to further suspect them of having
married with the intention of divorce
because by remaining aloof from the
members of a couple's respective houses,
they won't be called upon to make peace
and reconcile between waring spouses.
Even if, according to the strict letter
of the law, you have the right to opt
out of speaking to your in-laws. That's
the opposite of virtue.
So I guess these are among the tools in
Muhammad Hijab's tool belt for
how to convince your secret wife that it
needs to be kept secret. We don't want
to or how to avoid dealing with in-laws.
In-laws are going to make things more
difficult. Or how what what advice he
would give to Muslim men. Hey, if you
want to avoid some stuff with in-laws,
then keep things secret. Uh any thoughts
on this before we go?
>> Well, in the context of the previous
discussion with Daniel, uh it becomes
even more apparent, right? So, the
reason I put this in here is because of
um him wanting to avoid talking to
Aisha's in-laws, but in context of the
previous clip, I'm just now realizing
that this is also to avoid any proof,
right? That this isn't just him not
wanting to do something. This is a way
to avoid any evidence because if there
are in-laws who know about it, they
could testify in court, right? They they
could say, "Yeah, they were married. We
we know about this."
>> So, if you keep everyone out of it, you
don't let anyone know about it other
than the the woman obviously and a
couple of your buddies that you
convinced to uh lie for you, then you're
good. No one will ever know. You can't
be proven in court. You can't be held
responsible.
Yeah. So, um, sounds like actually
sounds like there's the real reason you
want to avoid the in-laws, which is you
don't want them to be wi to be able to
testify as witnesses that you were in
fact married. So, that's the real
reason, but you need to explain to your
wife
don't want to talk to her in-laws. And
you don't want to say, "Well, it's
because I don't want any witnesses." Uh
so you say, "Oh, but you know, in-laws
make things so complicated and so on, so
why don't we just go ahead and uh you
know, stay away from that whole issue."
>> The fact that he is on video talking
about, oh, you need a few good friends,
this and that, and then there's this
group of 75 Dies, and then it just
pieces together like even an even fuller
picture of how who's the liar here and
who's the one telling the truth here.
Muhammad Hijab is basically talking
about himself and his own life scenarios
and what he did to get away with this
stuff.
>> Yeah, definitely. And
that that carries through. Again, almost
every clip I see from Muhammad Hijab for
the past couple years is him defending
lying. And the ways he's defending lying
are exactly the ways that he was lying
in life. And then when he's exposed for
all the lies he's been telling, he he's
actually he actually expects people to
believe him. He's like, "Hey, here's all
the situations where I think it's fine
to lie and I think we're I'm okay with
God if I lie in these situations." Then
he lies in all those situations and when
he's called out for it, um he expects us
to believe him, it's such it's it's
really really like like you wonder like
how dumb could his followers actually be
if they still believe him at this point.
>> The other crazy thing is that in um the
newest Salman video in the group chat,
Muhammad Hijab, you know, is saying,
"I'm going to post this video and
everybody come flood the comments." So
even in the comments you think, "Oh my
god, there's all these Muslims that
agree with him." But actually, it might
be just countless, you know, sock sock
puppet accounts of hijab's cronies in
there.
>> Mhm.
Wild stuff. All right. Now, we have
Knowledge North on Msar marriage.
>> Ms. is a kind of marriage light that
appears to fall between the halal and
the haram.
So, Albani ruled Msar to be invalid
because it invalidates the role of the
husband. If Allah has designated the man
to bewam maintainer and protector of the
women of his household, he cannot
abdicate from his role, even if his wife
does not mind forfeiting her right to
provision and maintenance.
Wild, wild stuff. Wild stuff. But that
is definitely a superior view to
Muhammad hijab.
>> Yeah. So I the point of this isn't to
say necessarily that uh you know Mishar
is not part of Islam or part of Sunni
Islam or anything like that but just to
show that there is legitimate
disagreement right Albani is not exactly
a lightweight here right he's a very
important figure in in uh you know
recent Islamic history and in his
opinion this isn't a valid part of uh
Sunni practice at all right the mission
is not a valid practice at all and of
course what hijab actually did isn't
even mishar it's just uh prostitution or
not even really prostitution right in
prostitution there's at least an
agreement from the woman but here it's
like just it seems it seems
>> it seems worse than mut
with muta you're actually you and the
woman would be agreeing this is what's
going to happen u we are agreeing that
we are going to be married for three
hours or a day or something like that
whereas here you're pretending that you
are intending to have a normal marriage,
but you're actually doing the same
you're actually doing the same thing uh
that you would do in a muta marriage,
but it's it's one-sided. She didn't
consent to this, but you you were
planning it. So, yeah, I think it's
worse.
>> Yeah. I mean, what what hijab actually
did is is more or less uh sexual abuse
or you could say rape, right? It's kind
of like a date rape scenario to use a
western term here where you uh pressured
a woman into something under false
pretenses. Uh she technically speaking
might have consented but she didn't
really consent because everything was
false from the beginning. And under US
law you could be prosecuted for that.
Right? You can go to jail for rape
charges for the kind of thing that
Muhammad Job did in this particular
circumstance.
weird.
>> I would argue that as well.
>> Yeah. You know what? If
>> Yeah. I think even in his own sorry um
just even in his own words previously,
he he described that as sexual
exploitation
uh in one of his videos. I don't know if
we have that video on the list.
Um and that implies great trauma to the
woman basically he's getting married to.
And there was no explicit consent to
this specific scenario with a specific
goal in mind for Muhammad hijab. And you
just wanted to hook up and and that's
it. No, there was that's not what you
wanted from the beginning. It's not what
you wanted when you did the nika. It's
not what you wanted when you went to
those hotels. None of this was actually
consent from you. You didn't consent to
this type of situation at all.
Um yeah, I just wanted to say that um
this is why I chose him. It was a choice
I made because I assumed he is better to
be trusted for better circumstances
because he's more trusted.
I trusted him more than the all the
other proposals I had. So if the
arrangement, this arrangement is what I
was looking for, I wouldn't have
left monogamy to the side and then gone
to to to marriage through to to through
something like this into something like
this.
This is crazy. There's no one who who
takes that such decision in their lives,
especially mothers.
Um this is something I had never agreed
to. It was never brought up to my
attention ever until he married me. And
uh basically as I said before, I assumed
he is more religious and more to be
trusted. I know you guys Christians and
um you are critics of Islam, you don't
agree to that obviously because he's
treats you in a certain way and whatever
the reasons are. But from an Islamic
perspective in the Muslim community,
based on the things that he used to um
advocate for previous to this marriage,
I based my decisions.
>> All right. Now we have uh one more clip
from knowledge north on miss marriage.
>> Oh, the scholars are more lenient.
These differences between the some
ruling ms are haram othersal can be
reconciled to an extent because there is
no dispute between the scholars that
were the husband to prove unable or
unwilling to maintain or fulfill his
marital responsibilities then the
marriage would be in jeopardy. and the
woman would be justified in initiating
divorce and suing for alimony. Nor is
there any disagreement between the
scholars that the parties cannot
stipulate in the marriage contract the
waving of either side's god-given rights
as all such conditions designed to
circumvent the Sharia are null and void.
The scholars's functional difference in
their ruling on Msar really stems from
how they approach the timing. For
Bimbars, at the point where the woman
who had previously waved some of her
rights decides she now wants them, but
the husband refuses to man up. At that
point, the Ms marriage fails. Whereas
Albani works backwards from the point
where the man is unable or or unwilling
to grant the wife all her rights. For
Albani, the very fact that the man
thinks he has a choice to maintain or to
not maintain his wife, he has reneged on
his fundamental role as a husband and
therefore the marriage fails before it
even begins.
>> So looks like knowledge north is
>> I'm going to
>> Oh, go ahead.
>> I'm going to give some clarification to
this point. So what he's trying to say
here is there are two different opinions
about this matter of MSR. So some
scholars say it's haram, it's
impermissible
of of for the husband to refuse to um
treat all his women equally. Polygamy uh
to say
uh it's haram for him to refuse to do
that in case the woman who he married to
who has previously forsaken some of her
her rights decides to ask for them. So
when she does, it's haram for him to
tell her, "No, I won't give it to you. I
won't give you uh your rights, and I'm
not going to it's not going to be
equally um like um I'm not going to be
treating you all the same equal way.
It's haram for him to do say this. And
if he continues in that marriage, then
that marriage is invalid. It's it's it's
haram." Okay. So the other opinion says
it's it's haram from the get-go if he is
incapable of fulfilling those
requirements in the future in case she
asks for those rights later on. So if he
knows from the get-go that he's
incapable of being fair to his women in
polygamy, he doesn't have the right to
go for missar.
Um but again as we said uh in the
beginning what Muhammad hijab was
looking for has nothing to do with
missar.
>> All right. So we've been through a lot
of information about this scandal with
Muhammad hijab. He's saying he's been
saying things for years and we've all
been wondering well how much of this is
he actually implementing behind the
scenes? As it turns out, he was doing a
lot of what he's been defending and so
was uh defending himself uh along the
way. And at the end of it seem at the
end of the day seems like that's pretty
much all he cares about in life is uh
defending himself against people
criticizing him for the horrible things
that he's done. All right, Hoda, you've
uh been through all of this stuff and
you've been following the story and
you've guys have been doing shows, but
uh uh why don't you share any final
thoughts on this whole issue before we
close out?
>> So, my biggest takeaway from all of this
is that there is a lot of dirty, slimy
things happening in the underbelly of
the the DA world, the DA bros. And what
I want to see is I want to see
accountability on behalf of other
Muslims. I want Muslims, all the famous
Muslims out there, anybody who follows
Muhammad Hijab, anybody who's out there
taking pictures with Muhammad Hijab,
high-fiving him, you know, speaking with
him at conferences, however you're
encountering him and engaging with him,
I want you to call him out. I want to
see a change in behavior from the
overall community that this is this has
got to stop where women are being used
and thrown away like garbage and
everybody's silent. We can't have
another imam Nick. We can't continue
this where people are silenced and
shunned and the behavior continues and
there's this protection, this culture of
protecting abusers and the bad people.
They need to be called out and it's time
to take out the trash.
Absolutely. Absolutely. Um Thaddius,
you've also It's weird because I feel
like I've done so many shows going
through this, but uh there are all these
people who know way more than I do about
the uh the whole situation, but uh
what's what what are your takeaways on
all this?
>> Yeah. So on uh what we viewed today,
first of all, um we saw a statement from
Muhammad Hijab kind of contradicting
what he's been teaching the last several
years. For the last several years, I I
don't know, maybe, you know, 10 years
ago, he wasn't teaching this. I I don't
know, maybe when he started in as a
public speaker in Islam, he had a much
more moderate position, but the last
several years, he's been teaching you
should just go by the technicality of
the law. And by the way, there are
multiple jurists opinions that conflict
with one another. So if you can just
find anyone that supports you, you're
good to go with that. You can use the
law as a tool to do whatever you want.
In fact, I encourage you to do that. I I
encourage you to find ways to get around
the Islamic law and get around the
national law of wherever you live as
well if you don't live in an Islamic
country to get what you want. Right?
find a way to use women for your benefit
because we we got this horrible scourge
of pornography and and adultery and and
the only possible solution is not for
men to behave better or or men to take
accountability, but is to find ways for
men to use women in a halal way instead
of using women in a haram way. And it
all comes down to technicality. So, his
statement that the the law is more
complicated, it's about harm, not about
uh the letter of the law, but the intent
and so on and so forth is great. Except
that's not what he's been teaching the
last several years. And he put that on
Twitter as a super long post in a
culture where people will only read a
sentence or two because he doesn't
really want to go on record correcting
himself. He doesn't really want to
distance himself from his views because
the views he's been espousing for the
last several years are his actual views
and those views lead to the abuse of
women. And then you have the broader
situation here, right? So you have
Muhammad hijab acting out on his own
practices and abusing Aisha. But then
you have the broader situation that many
other people are taking his vice.
They're looking at him. They're seeing
as some kind of hero and saying, "Oh,
yeah. If if he can do it or if he's
advising us to do it, of course, that's
great. That's good. Uh this is the mercy
of Allah that that we're allowed to do
this as men in Islam. So, let's do it."
And no one is speaking out against it
even after hijab has been exposed. Tons
and tons of evidence. There is zero
doubt in any rational person's mind that
hijab is guilty of all this. and his
guys not only are not speaking out. I I
before a week ago, I thought they were
just afraid not speaking out, but it
turns out they're actually conspiring to
help him cover this up behind closed
doors. And the whole situation is just
absolutely horrific.
Yeah, it is. Uh it's pretty bad. So,
you've got the you've got a bad guy
doing bad things and then you've got a
community of his loyal followers who are
willing to help him help him get away
with all of it.
Not good. Not good stuff.
Sister Aisha, why don't you share
whatever you want to share with
everyone?
>> Right. So I would like to highlight
first uh before I move on to my feelings
which obviously I'm sure many of in from
hijab sides don't care about I would
like to highlight first the following
points. What we have gone through was
not just these differences of opinions
or this mis um um explanation of of the
text and scriptures from the part of
Muhammad hijab and and the deception and
the sexual abuse and all of that. What
have we have gone through was the
slander that has followed because he
spread stories about me to those who
knew about the marriage and he worked
really really hard and and disgusting
ways to uh distort my image. Uh then
later on to distorted the image of
Sheikh Muhammad Arona and from his own
words sheh Muhammad Harona those other
ones who were part of the nikah. So he
distorted their image as well. He
blackmailed them too. So we are talking
here about blackmail, defamation. We're
talking about fabrication,
impersonation. We are talking here about
the use of gangs which is extracted from
his own video that he published on uh
false allegations. And my question to
him is as follows. How many gangs did
you use for your missions against me?
What were you spreading about me to
them?
What kind of missions did you send them
to? Um, how many texts and and documents
have you fabricated to um convince those
people who knew about the marriage and
get them to be on your side? How many
women had to go through these things?
How many women had to sign NDA forms, no
disclosure applications,
in order for them to stay silent and not
come out public to speak against this
abuse that could have happened to them
from other guys in in in in the field?
Um, how many people had to go through
all these horrible things?
My my statement is we have to keep in
mind all the horrible things and crimes
that have been committed and there are
so many including like his accusations
to me that I am an enemy of Islam that I
am an apostate that I am mentally ill.
My identity has been um revealed to
thousands of people in the community
from the personal information that was
shared online.
Um there are there's my family, my
friends. So I am not anonymous. I am not
unknown. I am known to thousands of
people and all these things that I have
gone through have harmed me
significantly.
In the name of all the women who have
suffered all these things, I am saying
these women are going to have to deal
probably for so many years or for the
rest of their lives with the
implications of these crimes. the
trauma, the incapability of trusting men
and getting married next and moving on
and creating their own families. They're
going to be um uh traumatized
spiritually. Probably they will leave
Islam and still yet they are going to be
um attacked for that.
Um my thoughts go to the the kids of the
single mothers that have gone through
all these things including my daughter
to their parents pre probably elderly
parents who had to look at their
daughters go through this suffering and
their grandchildren.
I am calling for change.
>> Yeah. Um, and I'll go ahead and I'll go
ahead and share my thoughts on this
whole situation and I'm I'm just
speaking directly to Muhammad Hijab. We
know
Hijab, we know you're listening because
you're a narcissist, so we know you're
you're watching all this eventually. Um,
so let me go ahead and let me go and
break down my problem. Hijab, it's not
it's not because we've had our
disagreements in the past or because uh
we've argued in the past or something.
this particular situation. Let me break
it down for you.
So this is the book of Genesis here,
chapter one. This is the opening chapter
of the Bible. hijab.
The first chapter of the Bible says,
"Then God said, let us make man in our
image, after our likeness, and let them
have dominion over the fish of the sea,
and over the birds of the heavens, and
over the livestock, and over all the
earth, and over every creeping thing
that creeps on the earth." So God
created man in his own image. In the
image of God, he created him. Male and
female he created them. And God blessed
them. And God said to them, "Be fruitful
and multiply and fill the earth and
subdue it and have dominion over the
fish of the sea and over the birds of
the heavens and over every living thing
that moves on the earth." Uh, check out
that middle verse. Hijab says, "So God
created man in his own image." That's
the generic sense of man in like the
sense of humanity. And we know because
it says, "In the image of God, he
created him. male and female he created
them. So you have God creates human
beings
and male and female he created them. He
created male and female in his image.
And what does that mean? Well, in the
ancient world, uh kings, rulers,
emperors, and so on, they would put
images of themselves in various parts of
the kingdom to remind people of their
dominion and authority and so on.
And so in the Bible images are
forbidden.
Uh but God says that h why? Because he
said he he made his own image. God made
his own image. Human beings. And what
that means is that we're supposed to be
reminding people. We're supposed to be
reminding each other of God. It's what
we're supposed to be doing. And in other
words, like just as an image of the
ruler in the ancient world was supposed
to remind you of the ruler, we're
supposed to be reminding each other of
God. And that can that can happen in
various ways, but it's supposed to be
for
the good of each other. That when you're
looking at someone who's sort of
reflecting reflecting the will and
nature of God and so on in various ways,
that's what's supposed to be going on.
And what happens is God also gives us
all sorts of abilities that are
associated with this. So for us to be
the image of God, we have to have uh
some amazing abilities. But what happens
when we get these amazing abilities?
Well, we use them for horrible things.
We use them to do horrible things like
like just think just think of all the
different abilities hijab that God gave
you that you are using to abuse women
and then to cover up what you've done.
Right? it that that takes a lot of
ability. You failed, but God gave you
the ability to do certain things and you
use those abilities to do bad things.
Well, guess what? All of us all of us do
that.
Some more so than others, but
all of us all of us use our God-given
abilities to do bad things. And so, we
fall into sin. And so, what we actually
look like is is something like this. So,
this is a plane crash, but it's like
this is what we look around and see.
This is what we look around and see. A
bunch of human beings who have damaged
themselves and been damaged by others
and we're damaged by sin and we're
damaged by the abuse we uh carry out and
so on. And so, we look around and see
these kinds of things. And that's not
exactly reminding you of God. That's not
exactly reflecting God. But what would
happen is suppose you'd never seen an
airplane before and you just see this.
Like if you had no idea what an airplane
was and you just saw this, a crashed
wrecked plane,
you could kind of look at that and tell
it's made for something important. It's
made for something really amazing and
awesome. And so that's what we kind of
look around and see at the world. We see
human beings who are flawed and who do
horrible things and we can treat each
other horribly, but we can kind of look
at ourselves and say, you know what, it
looks like we're meant for something
amazing. It looks like we're meant for
for great things.
And so what you do is you look to some
if if you're looking around and you see
everyone and we're all damaged to one
extent or another, what you'd want to do
what you'd want to do is see like a
perfectly functioning example. And
that's what we have with Jesus according
to Christianity. But I would say even
according to Islam, according to Islam,
uh Satan touched every child who was
born into the world but couldn't
couldn't
touch Jesus. And so Jesus is called
blameless in the Quran. But Jesus is the
perfectly functioning example of someone
who is the image of God. And so we're
supposed to look to Jesus and
basically live up to what we were meant
for, right? And you can't do that on
your own. You need the spirit of God.
But that's the idea. It's we are made to
be the image of God. We're made in the
image of God. We use the abilities we're
given for uh for ourselves for selfish
purposes and so on. But we have we we
have the ability to sort of look and see
what we are meant to do and to become
more and more like that. And so what I
see from you, Hijab, what I see from
you, Hijab, is your goal is to is to
keep people like this, right? Is to keep
people, right? That people aren't
looking to you. I'm talking about your
followers and anyone else. People aren't
looking to you and seeing here's what
it's like. They're not looking to you
and saying, "Wow, here's what it's like.
Here's what I need to live up to." It's
this is the example of you and you're
convincing everyone else to be more like
this, to be more uh more destroyed and
it just seems like you cause destruction
all around you. And so that's that's
really what what ticks me off in all of
this. Muhammad hijab,
this is why especially in the Bible
leaders are held to such a high
standard. You have influence over other
people. If you
are massively defective and you're using
your abilities to abuse other people,
that's bad. That's one thing. But if
you're a leader and you're showing other
people that that's how to treat other
that's how to treat their fellow human
beings, you are in serious serious
serious serious danger with the
Almighty, my friend. And so when I look
around and I see you,
it's not it's not just Aisha and not
just any other women you're abusing.
Again, it's your own followers and so
on. When you when you have people who
trust you, and you use it to make
yourself the center of the universe,
making yourself an idol to people to
lead them away from God. You're in
serious danger, buddy. And you need to
get right. You need to get that right.
And so, this is kind of one big
intervention. Muhammad hijab. You can
look at everything that's happening with
uh knowledge north and
uh and Salman and Aisha and us here.
It's one big intervention. It should be
your closest companions, but they're
they're all brainwashed.
But think of it as an inter intervention
from people who've seen
the things you've done and are calling
on you to change your ways. You need to
look at the damage you're doing to your
own community, to
your own family, to your wife, your
current wife, and however many uh other
wives you have, and then of course to
your ex-wives. You need to look at the
consequences of your actions. Quit being
so insanely selfish. Be a man for once
in your life. Stand up. Acknowledge what
you've done. Decide to change. Stop
treating people this way. And
I would suggest I would suggest
seriously rethinking your views if this
is what your views uh have led you to.
All right. I just wanted to thank
everyone for joining us and uh watching
uh these two uh these two discussions
with sister Aisha and going through all
these clips and seeing some of these uh
some of these issues. Um whatever else
happens we can everyone here everyone on
this end of the discussion we all agree
um don't treat people the way Muhammad
Hijra Muhammad hijab treats people don't
be like that and if you do treat people
like that you need to be exposed and you
being exposed isn't just for the good of
other people it's for your good too
because you don't want to spend the
entire life uh treating people that way
and damaging people. So thanks to
Thaddius and Abdullah and um Huda and
especially sister Aisha for joining
together. Like to thank everyone for all
the work they put into this uh Salman
and so on. And uh everyone be sure to
share this information because you do
still have people trying to cover things
up and uh blame everyone except the one
who really needs to be blamed in all of
this.
So don't let them get away with this
anymore. and for the good of all of our
brothers and sisters in humanity, let's
put an end to this nonsense.
>> Thank you for um your collaboration and
for allowing this to happen and uh
giving me a platform to advocate for the
virgin of Islam I believe is the correct
one.
>> Yep. And thank you for thank you for
joining us and we'll catch you all next
time. And any updates in the future,
we'll keep you all updated.